good morning everyone we're going to
begin seeing as though the hour is
exactly 9 o' on
Wednesday March 5th
2025 begin this work session a continued
work session by request for the
Department of Health and Human Services
Division of
Medicaid for the record I am state
representative Moren money of the town
of marac I'm the vice chair of division
3 our chairman representative Jess
today we also have today scheduled a 1M
work session on House Bill 71 so that's
on the docket for division three
today so the purpose of today's work
session as a continuation is to go over
a few key areas that weren't uh covered
too deeply the last time we met which by
the way was Friday February
21st so I know there is a very well
organized and thoughtful presentation
that we'll go through and the hope is to
cover provisions of house build 2 now
that that has been
the trigger law discussion on the
trigger law that New Hampshire has is
one of very few states that have that
law and then any other questions or
concerns since our last work session on
Medicaid uh that may have gone
unanswered or we need answers to um to
be
clarified so we hope to touch upon those
as well as other things in the
presentation so before we begin uh with
our our Witnesses today anything further
from members of division
3 all
right with that we are all set to begin
at your leisure welcome house finance
division
3 good morning members of the committee
uh Nathan white Chief Financial Officer
with the Department of Health and Human
Services and I'm joined here this
morning with I'm Henry Litman the
state's Medicaid director so we
um we have prepared a
presentation uh and IT addresses a
couple of additional items in addition
to to what you had indicated
representative money um and there's two
handouts in front of you one is all of
the um the the additional coverages and
rate increases provided um or approved
by the legislature and approved by CMS
over the past um 6 years since 2019
as as requested and then the second is a
presentation and so I'm going to hand it
over to Henry to move us through the
presentation and we're hoping as we move
through that we'll be able to address
questions so in this document the the
actually what would otherwise be a
PowerPoint document um thankfully it's
not a PowerPoint um we have uh what we
took away from the questions that had
come up uh as we recorded um from last
session um one of the things that we
wanted to do which we hope we achieve
with uh the fir in section one is just a
crosswalk between the adjusted
authorized budget and the governor's
budget for 26 the 25 budget versus
26 um we talked a little bit about how
hard it was to um follow the change in
how uh the dish program is working so we
put together an exhibit to um show you
where to find the different pieces so
you can put it all together um then we
have uh that separate handout that uh
Nathan referred to a moment ago that
goes through um service additions and
eligibility changes for the past six
years um we have some enrollment and
eligibility follow-ups uh based on the
discussion um we had uh the there was a
question about Dental rates we have an
exhibit to address that and other
information which I think uh you're
interest in going through hb2 more
specifically now that it's published and
that's what we have for today um and so
if I could draw your attention to page
three and I think um GNA ask Nathan to
uh to address that exhibit for us sure
so on page three at in the top box there
you'll see the state fiscal year 25
adjusted authorized and this is
representative of the total Medicaid
Program and um the adjusted authorized
figure you will see is higher than State
fiscal year 26 Governor uh recommended
budget and in the details below there
we've we've listed out the some of the
changes that that account for some of
those
differences um the the reduction in
annual Medicare uh management increase
so so this is uh coming from accounting
unit 7948 where we see a lot of the
changes there this is resulting from the
premium and some of the return to
standard uh to to uh pre-pandemic uh
eligibility standards there there's the
pharmacy cost sharing component which
also has a corresponding hb2 provision
uh which we will uh go through hb2 here
in a little bit um there were and here's
the return to regular eligibility
processing there for the 11.4 million
the children's premium up to 5% of
household income that's another 3.3
million and again I just want to make it
clear this is this is for State fiscal
year 26 only it's not both years we
tried to keep this simple but we also
tried to make it as clear as possible so
you can kind of crosswalk the
differences um the Hamstead change in
ownership uh technically we're leasing
out Hamstead now uh to Mary Hitchcock
Memorial Hospital so the dish dollars
were no longer needed to be budget
budgeted and there's a reduction there
um the dcyf residential budget so what
we what we did here is we had adjusted
the amounts within Medicade to be at a
5050 level um because this current year
uh just due to some of the changes at
the federal law some of that had to be
paid out at 100% federal funds and
that's been moved some of those dollars
have been moved to 20 or accounting unit
53 if I'm remembering correctly and we
and we will have that crosswalk it's
sitting in my email I just haven't had a
chance to validate it before I send it
over to you so you can see how the
residential um contracts are budgeted
across multiple Aus I just want to make
sure I get that to you and it's correct
and then the um below that the updated
Community Based Support Services
utilization this is for uh wraparound
Services there's been an adjustment
there and then the enhanced match under
the 80% plan in state fiscal year
25 and so when you crosswalk those
changes um that that shows you sort of
how how we go from the adjusted
authorized to the to the governor's
budget I'm hoping that was helpful in
terms of trying to piece those pieces
together yes thank you very much for
that
clarification um if I could Madam sorry
representative tarki for a
question it's really early since we're
starting an hour early so I'm getting my
coffee together can we just break it
down make sure I fully understand what
we're looking at here so these numbers
are for 26 only 2026 only okay and the
for example
1.5 million is the savings for the farm
co-pay cost sharing estimate only yes
okay um and one additional point of
clarification this represents total
funds so so in for the pharmacy cost
sharing component each year it's
750,000 General funds but when we do the
ma when we add the matching federal
dollars we we then it's 1.5 million so
so I just want to make sure that just
cuz it is early in the morning it's a
little earlier than we typically start
um it it's the total funds amount that
you're looking here looking at right
here okay so
you're with that logic then you're
estimating there will be
$750,000 coming in for the pharmacy cost
sharing for the first year is that
correct am I understanding that
um okay I might have more questions but
that's helps me just understand what I'm
looking at
thanks representative Stringham for a
question yeah so the pharmacy cost
sharing is that is that the uh increased
co-pay or is that the joint venture um
that you were talking about for high
cost
Pharmaceuticals no that's exclusively
the going from $1 to $2 to just four up
you representative priest for a question
thank you Madame Vice chairman um on
that second table would it be possible
to break down that second column into
General funds and federal funds so we
know exactly what we're looking at and
how much General funds this would be
saving uh yes uh we we we can provide
that we'll also add a third column with
other funds as well okay thank you so
much
very good um so if you could go to um
slide four um which is the Medicaid
enhancement
tax um we had provided I think the top
half of this exhibit as part of the
prior presentation we added this bottom
uh table um so that you could track
where the dollars land as a result of
moving from paying um completely dish to
paying a combination of um higher rates
uh directed payments and Dish um and
what's reflected in here is the um I
think it's colloquially known as the 80%
plan which um where things landed at the
end of last uh legislative session and
representative Nano has a question yeah
I apologize I'm still like quite awake
awake yet either but this is a a a
question and maybe there's no answer to
it but uh if you had any indication that
there going to be changes in the
Medicaid expansion side of it and and
whether you've looked at any
sensitivities uh because of the existing
uh legislation in New Hampshire that if
the 10% if less than 90% of federal
funds comes under that program that goes
away the
if I could uh you're really addressing
the trigger law that's in current law
yeah exactly and
um chair person you had mentioned there
are a few states there actually I
believe 10 or more now that have a
trigger law in the in the US um and so
what that says under our statute is that
should the the federal match go below
90% there's a certain period very short
period of time I think it may be 10 days
or 5 days to alert the legislature and
legislative leadership and then um 180
day U wind down of the program um I
think that also gives the legislature if
they so chose to look at whether they
want to do anything different depending
on how much the 90% goes
down so my my question is is that you
know um given the fact that we have that
existing trigger in the legislation and
for planning purposes have you all
looked at a sensitivity case that uh
that addresses that possibility um I
think we have sort of at a at a a global
level I mean I think that um there's so
many different scenarios right now we
know that if it goes below 90% current
law is that it ends unless there's a
legislative action to make it different
um and so we all the funding there um
give me a
damage so in um State fisol year 25 um
you know the the total cost of that
program which is um by legislative
design um is not on budget um is uh
expecting to spend and um in program
costs
620 um1 million just for rounding um and
that uh the um the 90% match generates
um about
582 thou 582 million um and then there's
a remainder amount which is funded by a
combination of um premium taxes that are
on the policies themselves um there's
also a component from from liquor
currently and there's also a component
from the New Hampshire health plan which
is sort of the high historic high-risk
pool and so that the difference between
the 620 and the 582 comes from
sources okay so the answer is you have
at least looked at that on a on a high
level level as what the potential impact
of that would be not withstanding the
fact that it has a lot of arms and legs
on it in terms of you know the wh ifs
and what the legis might do or not do
correct thank you so just to clarify the
trigger law is a chapter law section 342
colon 12 uh of 2018
correct representative tki for a
question yeah I am just curious um
because we started talking about the
Medicaid enhancement tax did you have
more information prepared on the trigger
law that we can wait and get to that
later I just don't want to disrupt your
your flow no I don't think there's much
more to the trigger law other than that
that basically if the federal government
reduces the 90% the law says we have to
notify legislative leadership um I think
it may be five days um and then we have
to notify the the people who have the
benefit that um it is scheduled to end
in 180 days the 180 days I think is
where the legislature could if it so
chose to do something
um while this may be
premature um is there and I think this
may connect a little bit to the
questions that were just asked um is
there any way there could be some kind
of look at data that says if we drop to
88% funding the state would need to find
x amount of money if we drop to 85%
funding the state would need to find x
amount of funding or the variables just
too extreme that we can't even talk
about those hypothetical
situations so um since there's a
Prohibition um which is not part of the
trigger law but generally for uh the
granted Advantage Program there's a
Prohibition against General funds so
looking to the sources of where we could
get additional funding as it under
current law is is really the the three
sources that I mentioned and um you know
the liquor fund which you know to my
understanding there's you know there's
um the growth in that revenue is not um
as great as we'd like it to be um there
is the the premium tax which is fixed
based on the policies and then under
current law there's also the New
Hampshire Health pl's contribution is
fixed to no more than 50% of what liquor
revenue and premium tax does so it may
to put more money in there is also a
provision um under um from 2019
hb4 uh that allowed uh the the
department to request additional liquor
funds which um happened during the
pandemic when the enrollment went from
you know in the low 50,000 to over
96,000 that um there was a need to tap
into that um so there is something on
the books that gives a little bit but
that's um you know I'm not sure how much
really you know liquor could afford um
based on what legislature decides to do
with money from liquor profits um that
could be done there so I think that's
the limiting factor in terms of what
would be under current legislation well
to be fair if there's limiting factor
that we need to take action and change
the statute to be able to um fix the
trigger law then we can change the stat
statute to what funds are used is that
accurate I I think that the statute can
be changed if you so choose I mean I
think that is it could be done
proactively or it could be done upon
upon action in that 180 day period but
here again depending on when that 180
day period came into effect you know
which is why I'm asking these questions
now for fear of the granted Staters are
going to be affected by this okay that
answers my questions I'm going to have a
lot more though so
I don't want to distract from where
we're going if I could add one thing in
terms of the timing of this I think that
it's likely that it appears that there's
the um there's the avoidance of the
government shutdown which is the um
continuing resolution and there's the
budget reconciliation I think the budget
reconciliation we may not know how that
lands until the fall in terms of knowing
for sure just just so you have a sense
what I see here in the chapter law uh
with regards to timing it says within 48
hours after the event under this
paragraph has occurred notify the
governor the speaker of the house and
the president of the Senate and the
chairperson of the legislative fiscal
Committee of the program's pending
termination that's what you were
referring to yes that was even quicker
than I thought and then it goes on to
say within 10 business days after the
event in this paragraph has occurred
notify program participant
participants of the program's pending
termination that's coming uh from the
chapter law I cited
earlier is also sorry I didn't mean
interrupt you and then what's the direct
wording for the termination date was it
180 days that you said
yes you you should see that there
somewhere if it's not there it might be
in a different part of that 342 chapter
we can give you the reference uh pull
that out for you and provide that to
great and I do see here
um and this is mid sentence so uh hereby
repealed 180 days after the event under
this paragraph occurs upon the
notification by the commissioner of the
Department of Health and Human Services
to the Secretary of State and the
director of legislative services and
then it goes on from there it's about
mid paragraph that's where I see where
180 occurs you found it okay real good
representative Neno for a question yeah
just a a quick question the Medicaid
expansion piece of it covers uh how many
people today uh uh we have uh exact
statistics for March 3rd but it's like
just under 59,000
today and um over the course of the last
year about 87,000 individuals have been
in the program and over the life of the
program um over a quarter of a million
uh New Hampshire residents have had some
time on the program the average tenure
on the program today is is less than one
year that's not to say there's people
that don't stay on for a period of years
but the average tenure is less than a
year so so are those numbers decre
postco those numbers are they've come
down decreasing excuse me um they have
come down from the high of 90 almost
97,000 to today just under 60 and it
seems to have leveled off on on that one
thing I would comment on though is what
we've seen is that um
individuals who have disabilities that
there I think that there's been a trend
for people to take advantage of um
getting on getting at least their health
insurance while they're waiting for
maybe um a waiver to come into play so
that I think some of the increases
related to that some of the increase
that we're seeing is um some of the
individuals who are pregnant um who have
postpartum coverage now for 12 months
that there's a portion there and then um
parent uh parent U child uh parent
caretakers excuse me eligibility group
that we see um some increase in
individuals using that and the reason I
think we see that is that the
eligibility criteria for granted
Advantage is purely um um your gross
adjusted income and
um which sometimes is referred to as
Magi so very quick fall so that suggests
to me that a that a portion of of this
that me you may still see declines
because a portion of this is transitory
the the yeah we our expectation is it's
going to land somewhere in the lower
50,000 ultimately but you know I think
that we need some more experience it's
really less than a not much more than a
year that we finish the unwind and and
trying to get a sense of the statistics
of how people are using it as sort of a
first step potentially to get some
Health Care coverage while they're
waiting for a waiver or disability
determination disability determination
take a while thank you and just want to
remind um everyone watching or listening
here that we are discussing uh what's
known as the trigger law in chapter laws
uh here in New Hampshire there's been no
action uh that we need to take that
would trigger this we are Simply Having
a discussion related to what this
chapter law
says representative priest for question
could you also cite the um statute and
sections again for
us yes this is a chapter law section
342 colon
2018 thank you ma'am and as for a
corresponding
RSA it seems there is isn't one
unfortunately this is the sort of thing
that probably should have gone into RSA
because it was intended to be permanent
however it's only in chapter
law representative tersi for question so
last um bium in hb2 when we put in the
sunset the seven-year Sunset um isn't
that in chapter law which I thought had
language to the
trigger um I need to look up that one I
don't recall where it went um I don't
think there was any language in that Rel
to the federal trigger though I think
okay I guess we discussed it and debated
to hopefully get rid of the trigger and
okay if I could Mr my recollection of
hp2 was that the changes that made it in
there were to address the
seven-year and then the sunset and and
and some of the funding with respect to
where liquor money went um outside of
the manage outside of the Medicaid
Program and the hospital contribution
which at one point was allowed but then
wasn't allowed by the
federal okay that makes sense
representative Stringham for a question
yeah well I was also going to um yeah
say this this the program sunsets in
seven years as you just said from that
and the the uh both the placement and
the location of the uh the trigger was
under considerable debate and it was
even
uh you know argued on the house floor of
whether the trigger law was still in
effect or not uh and ultimately I think
we decided the trigger trigger law was
still still in in effect so which is you
agree with so yes um anything about that
that's inconsistent with your
you thank you you may proceed um so I
think we were on uh page four at the
bottom was um just showing where the
Medicaid enhancement tax um and and the
revenues for that are are currently
accounted for
um as we mentioned before when things
move from being just paid out as a
disproportionate share payment for
uncompensated care and instead put the
Met um partially into rates and
partially into directed payments so that
we could obtain the more favorable
Federal match it just you see great
differences between prior years and this
is an attempt to um if you will give you
a program to to check which page where
those dollars ended up and on the right
hand far right hand side of the table um
you'll see that I will note the granted
Advantage Health Care Program local
funds you'll see an NA again because
budget representative tki for a question
thanks um so I think you said that these
numbers in 26 and 27 reflect
80% like the um the Medicaid enhancement
tax itself is the Top Line there the 286
the 337 the 350 those uh were the the
governor's budget um if you will the the
tax that was collected uh and then below
the the use of those funds um reflects
the
80% so in 25 that would have been the
sorry the older um figures in the older
calculations no in the adjusted
authorized no so um in in
25 again at the end of last session what
um I would add a a footnote here not to
add any confusion um the Medicaid
enhancement tax um and we've provided
this information to Kevin in terms of
what the um hospitals reported
um they make a non-binding estimate for
uh for the upcoming um payment due in
April that it was a l over 348 million
level 20 24 tax year paid in 25 can I
ask a quick question and and sort of if
you follow um on page five um we have
the on the left hand side the the top
line of
numbers uh the originally U the budget
amount was uh
319 uh
255 360 represented what um would go to
the hospitals under the 80% plan and the
63 840 is what's represented would come
to um the Department of Health and Human
Services this is not the federally
matched amount this is just the the
Medicaid enhancement tax amount um and
then down below that um you know going
again horizontally
the the non-binding estimate uh that was
provided in January the 348 million um
at an 80 um percent would be
278 and the balance to the state is the
69 and then the last line is the change
between the two numbers above in each of
the
columns and then that's repeated in 26
and 27 and then what I would note there
is that based on
25 um you know we've looked at what
rating agencies have said about what's
the trends in hospital revenues um and
um you know basically reflect that
likely we're going to see 4% higher than
what we saw in um in the assuming the
the non-binding estimate comes in as we
expected to um it would be we would be
expecting more than what was in the the
budget okay any questions on
that representative tki for a question
so I'm just wondering if um when working
out the
projections if there is consideration
for an increase in uncompensated care
based on the policy changes proposed in
hb2 for Medicaid premiums and the
assumed drop off that we have
discussed um so actually that's a good
lead into the very next slide I will
step back then thank you um I just
wanted to make mention and I'm looking
for it uh I can't put my finger on it
but there is a Senate bill right now
pending regarding this assessment tax uh
that may very well be headed our way I
don't know if you have any comment to
that I know Senator birdell is the one
and only sponsor I believe that's the
bill I'm referring to Yes um it's Senate
Bill
249 and um it has the policy committee
is passing it on to to finance they
didn't do anything more than what was in
that uh bill which still maintain the
80% it's going to Senate Finance uh I
believe in the near
future real good thank you
representative Neno for a question yeah
just a a very quick question so any to
the extent that that uh the me
overperforms that winds back up in the
general
fund the Prat share that is under an 80%
plan 20% of it would um the other
portion what's under current law would
always be 80% of whatever came in would
create the pool for the hospitals uh so
it isn't like every dollar that comes in
is really 20 cents on a dollar that but
that that doesn't wind back up in the
general fund um well it it does in in
part uh for the portion of services that
are um again this is another um tweak to
the law that was made I think in 2020 or
2021 that um a portion of of the
Medicaid enhancement tax that is paid
out and enhanced directed payments to
hospitals that those funds can be the
Medicaid enhancement tax dollars can be
used to um to cover that because
um to to make those payments to the
hospitals so so it's h held out for and
accounted for separately yeah it's um I
I think I have it on one of the line
items here I believe
it's
it9
med to fund it
you have it to yeah to grage
yeah
yeah it's approximately $9 million I can
come back give you an exact number um of
the proceeds to that go into uh funding
the
program okay thank
you
um going back to where representative
tki was was heading um on page um
six so the amount of uncompensated care
that states are able to pay out is each
state gets a dish allotment um New
Hampshire's dish allotment um if
Congress does not act there's currently
a congressional along the books that
says that state there um as a result of
of the ACA you know and and Medicaid
expansion that that there should be less
uncompensated care and so um in the
continuing resolution there was a
temporary 4month extension of a pause in
in that reduction so New Hampshire if
Congress does not act on that would see
a reduction of a 139 million out of a
out of a um a pool that's approximately
230 million so we would only have
available to us 905 million to make um
uncompensated care payments that's why
we've been moving towards the higher
payment rates and directed payments and
I think the the question there is you
know like many things Congress doesn't
necessarily always um continue what
they're tring to do it when they
sometimes delay um and you know I think
the the perspective has been thus far to
you know pause it a bit but I think
given what uh Congress is potentially
looking for for for a deficit reduction
you know I think there's some risk here
that we could see less of that so that's
why um putting um the Met dollars into
directed payments and uh payment rates
is is a good thing to a point um and
that um some level of of uncompensated
care in the form of dish payments for
the hospitals is a good thing and the
reason why is that
under um the the enhanced payment rates
and under directed payments those can
only go to Medicaid New Hampshire
residents Associated
Services um it it can't go for anything
else the the the dish dollars can go to
cover uncompensated care like a hospital
that sees like a Dartmouth Hitchcock who
sees a lot of patients from Vermont um
that that's where the the uncompensated
care dollars are important to the
hospitals in terms of being able to
develop a formula that addresses um the
distribution of this pool um and uh so I
think the the issue right now today is
we're not sure um if this is going to be
extended I'm sure there's great um
lobbying efforts to extend it um but uh
it is kind of tied to to okay the
government shut down kind of situation
does it does it get deferred more till
you know the budget reconciliation
process or do they um they take the
savings now um don't have a clear answer
on that I don't think anybody does uh
but even even if um this weren't in play
I think directionally the law is in
place for It ultimately happen which is
why you know starting in 2025 and really
actually a little bit before that we
started my ating using the Met dollars
sustainable um so um we're now on the
presentation and if you want us to hold
on this but this is where we were going
to pick up the the separate handout of
service changes and eligibility changes
enacted and
um there are 39 of these to to discuss
with you um they're um the majority of
them all but five are really either
federally um driven or by our New
Hampshire legislature driven um and
there are a few exceptions to that and
I'll cover those five
exceptions um representative priest for
a question uh thank you madam chairman
as a point of clarification this
represents what the impacts would be
if
Congress does nothing on the budget and
it just falls down to 90% no this is
this is really untethered from that
whole discussion this I think um this
was originally requested by the chair um
to understand what policy changes have
been made and and did did this committee
want to consider any changes to those
policy changes that were
enacted okay thank you thank
you representative Nano for a question
yeah just for clarification purposes
this really I I think if I recall recall
representative Edwards question it was
looking at the whole eligibility
question and so this relates to changes
in eligibility with the relative impacts
services and eligibility um that that
was what we got us the question from
representative Edwards thank you that's
what I understood the the question was
and how I understood this uh
thank thank you um representative
Stringham for question it looks like
you're also addressing rate changes
which doesn't affect eligibility but
impacts uh how much we pay
basically cost cost of living largely
cost of uh living increases but there
were some that were um singled out um uh
because there was um dramatic under
service in those areas so um so you've
included all of those is that right yes
we we consider those to be service
changes um and you know you could look
at them differently but I think we
wanted to be fully transparent as much
as we could have all the things that
have come up via legislative policy
federal policy and a few things outside
of that and the the last column
estimated cost that's annual um those
those those are uh tied to an annual uh
this they're represented in total funds
and then the breakdown where we have it
uh below um there are a couple here that
that uh we don't have a fund in them
because there may not have actually been
an increase in costs for example the
very first one um uh women could get um
12 12 months of oral contraceptives
before I think this particular uh
statutory change was to make it more
convenient to be able to get that in one
prescription as opposed to having to go
year if you're so my thought is to go
through them um just as a time check uh
we're almost 45 minutes in which is hard
to believe actually time flies here are
you okay with that yes I think a lot of
this can move fairly quickly depending
on the level of
right um and um this was uh is this is
tremendously helpful and informative the
way it's presented and the information
contained so I think it would be good to
have a um a rundown
sure um the number and I put we've put
numbers in the column first we were
going over it last night saying we're g
make it hard to follow if we don't have
some way of directing you to the one
we're talking about um so we're on
number number two now the Medicaid
assist medication assisted treatment um
is a mandatory benefit that was um
enacted by um Congress um and um so we
really don't have a choice if we want to
participate in the Medicaid Program and
I don't think it was something that we
wouldn't think was a good thing which is
to for people uh particularly older
people who U might need medic medication
assisted treatment um you know I think
sometimes that's under reported and from
what I understand in terms of the of
that issue for particularly the elderly
that uh may be um you know Home and
Community Based as an example so it
makes sure that that there's funding
available to provide that service um
then the the next one down were the
provider um rate increases enacted in
hb4 um the laws of
2019 um on the far right here do have
the um the total funding and then a
breakdown between the um the general and
federal funds and then the um accounting
column
um any questions on
okay representative priest for a
question thank you Madame Vice chairman
um again I think it would be very
helpful it would be very helpful to me
and maybe others on this committee if we
could see the faces behind each of these
programs and how many people you are
serving as of this year we will have the
statistics on this year um coming up in
the presentation um and uh we if if you
will after we do that if there's more
information than that if there's more
information you need or want beyond that
follow representative Stringham for a
question and 2020 provider rate increas
is that just a flat percentage increase
across the board that year um no I think
there were some targeted rate increases
for particularly for um inpatient um
mental health the drfs uh were um a very
large increase I think we like tripled
the rates for um to get more um
um we could if you want could put
together a summary but that off the top
of my head is I remember being one of
the larger components of of it um and
that's still included in here uh in this
because those rate increases basically
became permanent yes so that that was
part of the base already when we were
discussing provider rates two years ago
yes thank
you um the transitional housing I think
um when trying to put a face to this one
the type of population here would be um
a lot of individuals who might be in the
mental health or or substance use space
who um particularly discharging from New
Hampshire hospital or um or other um
mental health settings that you know
having a chance to have a place to to
reestablish yourself before um moving on
to a more permanent situation um in part
you know the the backup into the
emergency rooms um is because often
times um former commissioner shanet who
was at the time head of New Hampshire
hospital would say that you know we have
a back door problem we can treat people
but there's no place to put them in the
community you know even when they're no
longer in acute status so I think this
was an investment made to uh improve uh
discharge um opportunities for people so
they didn't have to remain um
Institution
Iz and then um I guess there's a
specific appropriation here for for drf
beds um this may have been there was
also a there were I think two components
the appropriation one was to increase
and one was the rate for those who are
already existing and then to encourage
new ones to come on board I believe that
that's what this one was
um um Supportive Housing um is again I
think a another um attempt to build out
the community- based resources for
individuals who are U affected by mental
health and substit use disorder
conditions again this is a temporary uh
funding to um enable someone to um have
a place to live and not be on the street
in terms of in a transition I think the
you know some of the major invest ments
that that have been made by the
legislature is trying to you know
improve the transition situation that
that we find ourselves in so we don't
have back up into the emergency room and
building out community services so that
people don't reenter institutions
because there are Community Based
Services available representative walner
for a
question um how are the how do people
receive this help is it a voucher kind
of program or do we actually have
places
that so live there's a there's a
screening process that like a case
management assessment of of it and then
um
there's uh support I'm not an expert on
this program but um basically there's uh
support to um help them get into a
housing situation you know some people
may need help with things like basic
household budgeting you know being able
to you know um be a good tenant um and
it's the basically the types of services
that would allow someone who may have
some challenges transitioning to a
independent living situation to have the
supports to to to do that transition
successfully representative nello for a
question followed by representative
priest yes thank you uh uh Madam
co-chair um so my understanding is the
difference between number four and
number six is really a length of time
issue or they look like they overlap so
they probably do overlap in the sense of
one is creating the the housing
opportunities and the other is sort of
the case management Care Management and
support so that um that they can
successfully be in a setting you know in
terms of you know landlord relations and
and you know household budgeting and
such that
okay you have a place to go but let's
make sure that you can
um so is it correct to you know I'm just
uh looking at is it correct to say that
uh some portion of the people in
transitional housing then uh take
advantage of Supportive
Housing it's it's possible but I to be
to be fair to you um there are other
people that have a lot more expertise on
this program than I do um and probably
uh would be in the um in Kota Fox's area
that would be able to talk more um
you um thank you madam chairman uh drf
can you just yes Define that for me the
the acronym stands for designated
receiving facilities they're uh
typically the high intensity mental
health sometimes um um it's someone you
hear the term committed um may be an
involuntary basis um and sometimes
people can go between involuntary and
voluntary or Sometimes They Come
involuntary in but it's more the more
intense cases that typically are you
know locked unit um okay and how many
beds are in each of these categories and
where are they located at um we'll take
that back as a question um that would be
great I just curious they're all
concentrated in uh Manchester you know
NASA and Rochester areas of the state so
on the drf beds um the most recent
addition um was Dartmouth Hitchcock um
adding some beds there that that's
probably the furthest North but like
Franklin um hospital and Franklin is has
drf but Manchester SE Coast the thing
about it's not just having the beds it's
having
psychiatrist all the trained nurses and
such to go with it um but I know that
other hospitals have looked at this
issue and try to evaluate it but you
know there is a shortage of U mental
health professionals that the state is
dealing with as
well thank you sure um number seven is
the children's system of care um and
again uh the children's Behavioral
Health people could tell you more about
this but
um in in 2019 um excuse me 2020 um think
building the system of care out more for
children that uh was I think probably
kacha Fox may have addressed with you
this is what this was the additional
investment made by the legislature to
help build out that system of supports
basically a lot of it being mental
health um for for children in terms of
um number eight um the is an action by
Congress to make sure that um
individuals in Medicaid have a chance to
participate in clinical trials um New
Hampshire um I don't think this meant
much to us because we had um you know
the ability to um have people
participate in clinical trials that were
appropriate um but uh this sort of
codified that you know it wasn't just
that it was a good thing to do but that
it needed to be done when it was
appropriate to give people access to
clinical trials um I know there's a bill
in this session somewhere about
expanding
um choices I think it's a um a bill in
Commerce about choices but in terms of
the Medicade program the access to
clinical trials is really not an issue
[Music]
um number nine is the adult Dental
benefit um that was enacted in
22 um and um you know implemented in
April of
um they
um
um I think uh the if you may recall the
the Dentures um uh was something that
the legislature wanted to provide to
people in waivers and in um nursing
homes um but not necessarily the the
public at large um and that are in the
program and so um we had to uh do a
special um state plan amendment to enact
that and then also there was an interest
in um certain populations um to uh to
have uh CAU sharing for dental
about
see trying to remember number 11 here
I'm going to have to having a little
brain cramp on what that that one was
but um I think it was and um probably um
expanding the the
um the use of
uh uh caregivers in in um you know in a
waiver situation but I'll let me have
someone verify that for
me
um then number 12 is uh birthing
Services um and this was to um increase
because of the closure of
we yeah so so I guess going back to
number to 11 um thank you Nathan for
helping me remember that one is you know
there was a significant shortage of Home
Care um available for personal care and
it um I think that gave us the authority
to be able to provide um some
compensation to family members under
certain um controls to be able to
support individuals that in their home
there were you know times when um you
know the during particularly during the
the closures that was very difficult to
get Staffing to keep maintain people in
their homes and this gave us some
um and and number 13 is also there were
certain um rules that were available to
us to provide personal care services in
the home um and when the federal Public
Health Emergency ended um there were
greater restrictions but still an
allowance and so what 13 um represents
is okay now that the the flexibilities
that were available during the public
health emergency or over we still had a
a Workforce shortage in the state and um
this was um a waiver that we were able
to uh obtain to continue to allow um a
certain level of of family based support
um and I will say this is it isn't just
sort of a free-for-all kind of thing
that they build the state they have to
we set up a a relationship with uh uh
Grand State Independent Living who make
sure sure that they're oriented and that
the hours attract and that that it's
based on something that has controls
around it's not a wide open thing that
you could just build the um but it's it
fills an important need where um home
care workers particularly um some of
our U families that have a severely
disabled child at home a case that you
know they may be on a ventilator and
they need or or have a tra and they may
need someone to help them come into the
home to be able to they want to keep the
child at home but they need some
supports to to do so and and we know
that typically it's two to three times
more expensive to institutionalize
versus maintaining at the home and then
also the the value of M keeping a family
together I think is is reflected there
representative Nano for a question
followed by representative pre thank you
madam chair uh so Mr liman so how do I
interpret the blank boxes under the
estimated cost uh so in that when we
were providing the service already and
so this was just it actually may be a
lesser cost in terms of um the personal
care
services so so a DI Minimus incremental
cost off of what we're already doing is
that how I interpret that on this
particular one I think it's probably a a
reduction as opposed to an increase um
because the the criteria to be able to
do it were tightened a little bit and um
so that that's that's why I don't think
it really if it's di Minimus it's it's
di Minimus moving in the direction of
you thank you madam Vice chairman and my
question is along with my fellow
representative um I I get the feeling
that these blank spaces on the estimated
cost are the ones are not being funded
they have no funds they're on the books
and that's the way it is is that correct
um no that I would say that um in the in
um what I'll try to do is go back as I
go forward is address the blank spots
for
you sure um so I think Nathan was
suggesting if if something is in our
state plan it's already built into our
budget and sometimes it's you know a
modification of something that we're
already doing like for example the medic
medication assist treatment you know
we're already doing it and we're
just New Hampshire was Progressive in
terms of its treatment as an example and
so when they put in that Federal
requirement it didn't really change what
we expected to provide and services but
if we're already doing shouldn't there
be a cost to that well I think what we
when when we do a state plan Amendment
um if there's an additional cost cost
it's here if it's if we believe it's
already built into our base we don't we
didn't include it okay thank you so
we're coming up to another example that
nicotine cessation counseling is um I
think this allowed um pharmacists to be
able to to be able to provide some of
um number 15 um 16 17 were part of the
mnib legislation that was passed um in
2023 um these do have um increased costs
and which are noted um uh on the far
right
column um lactation Services was
basically we already provide lactation
services but this was allowing um
additional settings for which that to
occur and additional um
qualified individuals to to be able to
provide that
service um the the duo service
um was passed into law there was um it
got Consolidated into hb2 there was a
component of rule making that was
unfortunately left out of the the um
when that happened so we had to go back
and get um working with off office of
professional licens your oplc is
actually under their jurisdiction to um
to get that rule making Authority that
rulle making Authority is is is going
through there you may recall Senator
Whitley in in terms of this particular
issue wanted to make sure there was good
stakeholder engagement in developing
this service and um we're hoping that uh
um you know we're we're in the process
of of uh getting ready to put this into
place I think this is is a service that
um does have a cost with it in the short
run but in the longer term um I think it
actually potentially could be a cost
savings to the department um and similar
to like Dental you know we know that
there'll be emergency room savings but
when we you know try to be conservative
about how we put together projections we
talked about that there would be you
know potential savings by you know
supporting making sure people are
getting their free natal care making
sure they're getting their appointments
making sure they're getting their
followup care all things that I think
are good to good maternal Health um and
um you know they're when you look at
this service it's a you know Arkansas
for example um is one of two states that
have not yet adopted the the um Extended
postpartum coverage but they have
legislation going forward this session
um to not only do the 12 months of
continuous coverage but to also to on a
presumptive basis provide dual coverage
association with it I think there's you
know um you know there sometimes a
perception that this is a luxury service
it's it's really not for for individuals
who I think would take advantage of it
Program representative Nano has a
question well maybe a comment I I was
gonna ask the question I think you
answered that that the duala uh program
would have offsets uh elsewhere like
those
not yet accounted for I guess given the
lack of experience with that program
that means that you have somebody who's
that that service is probably a lot
cheaper than somebody being in a
hospital to make a
delivery yeah I mean if when you look at
complications at Birth and you know um
that can happen and um that um you know
the postpartum coverage and making sure
that people are getting the services
that they need so that you know you
don't have
bad events happen I think there there is
a savings there but hard hard to
quantify it will happen over time and
and a lot of what I think the
legislature has
passed in terms of like building out the
children's system of care adding you
know resources in certain places is you
know when someone stays in an emergency
room as an example that's a very
expensive place to stay if you if we can
move people into a community based
service and keep them there the cost to
DHHS and the public at large is
typically Less in terms of in many
different areas whether it's the courts
or the police or um you know excessive
use of services um so that that I think
is um I don't think there's a lot that
you'll see when we go through this that
that I think um would make sense if
you're trying to manage long-term cost
to to to go back on like you know
postpartum care I think is really
important and when you look at at some
of the um you know the national
statistics on these issues U that you
know trying to to avoid um mortality and
to and other issues I think there there
are a lot of good things that you know
we've been fortunate to be able to to do
I understand with the budget in front of
us there there a period of what we will
try to make what we implemented work
better I think is is is really what I
would
encourage um yeah so I would just say
that that the other piece of this is a
risk assessment on the part of
individual users on the
service okay thank you um uh donor
breast milk is um this is not people
giving milk to one one another it's it's
going through a uh a specialized
facility and it's typically there are
utilization criteria where an infant has
to meet certain um weight and other
conditions to be able to get access to
this uh and again it's you know making
sure a child starts life in a healthy
way and and you know when that doesn't
happen we have long-term costs in the
place Madam chair quick quick question
so that's through representative Neno
for a question that's through an outside
agency like LTI or U some other
organization that so so there's a I
believe there's a facility in
Connecticut that U that Banks the milk
and Dartmouth Hitchcock I believe is our
is the one that actually distributes it
uh and I'm not sure if there's another
hospital that that is doing it today but
I know Dartmouth was was one of them and
obviously they see a lot of the more
premies and things like that there right
thank
you mobile crisis is sort of the rapid
response to um providing Mental Health
Services in the community um here's an
example of something that wasn't
legislatively mandated but the
department saw while we're doing this
service um there's potential to get um
because Congress passed something that
provided an enhanced match you know the
state had an interest in um building out
mobile crisis so all communities in the
state could be served uh when um
a certain definition of services is
provided the state instead of a 50%
match um in those instances gets an 85%
match um so it was something that seemed
to be a prudent thing to to do since we
were going to provide the service
irrespective oron already were um so
that was an instance of something that
wasn't legislatively required of us but
Congress made this opportunity and and
um since we look to provide the service
um that uh we we sought that uh state
so
um number uh 19 um let's see this this
gets into um what were the hb2 rate
increases I think we have all seen
stories about the challenges that um the
EMS Community is having um you know on
the Sea Coast up north um you know labor
shortages you know as certain Hospital
services are closed like maternity um
you know that ambulances in small towns
have to go further away which sometimes
leaves the towns uncovered um and so I
think this was um trying to bring our
rates to um Medicare levels um and
um it was achieved in part of uh of hb2
now price changes will happen thereafter
there's um legislation that was enacted
I think we come later on to um also
provide some support to to um ambulances
in terms of times when ambulances go out
to a setting they may to provide
treatment but they don't actually have
to transport and um we we'll get to that
representative Neno for a question yeah
I just want to make the comment that uh
that was greatly appreciated especially
in rural communities such as in the
district that I represent where that
increase made a big difference in
especially in the cases where they made
a call provided services but because
they didn't transport weren't
compensated for it so I want to thank
everybody that was involved uh in
helping to get those rate rate increases
and I also you know it had the secondary
benefit I think to um a former city
counselor had nine terms in Laconia and
you know in terms of what what uh
taxpayers have to pay to provide EMS
Services it also help Town budget so I
think it had a double benefit if you
will as I recall last turn
representative Stringham had a hand in
proceed Mr
Lipman
um the next one um is again another hb2
provision um trying to remember which
one that's for if you can look at that
for a moment the state plan service the
general one there
sure sure um what what Nathan suggest we
actually put together a report for
fiscal committee um which was required
in hb2 that shows um the 100
approximately $134 million in
Appropriations and where it went um a
large part of it did go to um the
Community Based Services Home and
Community Based Services which has made
a difference in terms of access there
but rather than maybe going through all
these I could um send to you that um
letter that went to fiscal terms of
saving a little bit of time here yeah
and and at a high level um how the $134
million um was allocated essentially
there was a 3% rate increase effective
July 1 of the first year of the spum and
then there was a portion of funds that
was allocated for targeted rate
increases that took effect during the
second quarter of State fiscal year 24
and then the remainder went into effect
January 1 of um excuse me the first yes
of January 1
2024 uh and and the the document that
that Henry referred to that provides a
high it provides a couple of
spreadsheets as well as a high level
overview of how those um how those rate
increases were were allocated and a
portion of them were at the
commissioner's discretion um identifying
uh High higher needs areas or areas
where the rates were uh a little more a
skew with standard Medicare or
um number
25 um I do have a dollar value for this
one and I I'll have to Circle back on
that
um but and representative Neno for a
question very quick question the the
overlap between item 16 which is the
duala the uh birthing centers and The
Midwives so I I was kind intrigued by
the fact that uh less allocated for
midwives which is kind of the more
traditional um uh
alternative uh is it because the duala
thing is new that it got allocated more
funds
or and and is there an overlap in those
three
items so there was um I think in in
um so so they they they actually
represent different actions so so the
The Midwives was a rate increase whereas
the The Duel is that was adding the
coverage okay yeah so it's it's not
necessarily one: one what you're looking
at here and birthing centers is a
totally different you know midwives
aren't using birthing centers so so
there's a a technical the facility
component to birthing centers for the
facil like a hospital right there's
typically you go when you have a
hospital admission you you pay the
hospital for sort of the in tional can
the doctor component the equivalent here
would be the Midwife has a professional
component there those are the with five
yes so I think I can um Jump Ahead to
um 25 I'm going to um come back with a
number but part of
um when we get into the waiver
discussion a little bit more um
there are two things that have um have
gone on and you'll see a couple more
references in general we we applied for
a waiver um with the approval of the
governor to um support transitions of
individuals coming out of the correction
system and um there're about 20
something states that have um G have
this waiver and what it allows for
there's typically what they call an
inmate exclusion that Medicaid dollars
cannot be used um in behind the full
walls so um New Hampshire's approach to
this um what we saw from data um that
Department of Corrections and um um the
Council of state governments analyzing
New Hampshire's why do people have
recidivism back into the correction
system it's often because of mental
health or substance use disorder issues
so the the goal of this program is to
provide a limited benefit which now the
feds will share in the cost um that will
probably the most valuable one to the to
the corrections is discharge
prescriptions rather than um the the
state or the county having to pick up
the discharge prescription that a 30-day
supply of medication for uh can be
provided
um to an individual so that's on the
cost side I think that is a value um
because um among the transitional issues
that someone has is if you can't get
your medications you sometimes end up in
emergency rooms which is a lot more
expensive for us in Behind the Walls if
you will um part of the the transition
is to um planning is to connect them to
the types of providers that they're
going to need need to see um when
they're when they leave the correction
setting so for example they might get if
they have mental health treatment or
substit disorder treatment in behind
prisons the state has been investing
with state general dollars uh to get
people uh rehabilitated or to provide
services that are needed um so rather
than having them leave the prison um
setting or uh or the correction setting
and have no connection to the community
providers there's a higher chance that
they're going to have a problem and end
up back in which is a costly setting so
for for fairly small dollars in the
Medicaid
Program um in fact this this waiver has
to be budget neutral um uh That We
Believe by providing better transition
management preparator
transition management meaning connecting
providers people to their providers that
they're going to need
outside um making sure they have the
medications they need and if they
qualify for Medicaid when they leave
which they probably would since they
have no income coming out that we get
them connected so that there's a
successful transition and that if
services are accessed they're accessed
in the least costly setting because you
know my experience before coming to the
state I work for hospitals for several
decades and you know one of the things I
observed in the community I lived in is
that people would bounce from um the
county uh prison to the emergency room
because sometimes they didn't have the
medications that they needed um and it's
not just mental health it could be their
their cardiac met or blood pressure met
or something like that so I think what
the idea here in this
waiver is to make sure that we manage
transition so people could be successful
and and build upon the investment the
state has made while they've been behind
bars and then to try to make them um
have an opportunity to be productive
person in society as well um and so
that's kind of what's behind that one
and there's also um a federal
requirement which I'll talk about a
little bit more later too for juveniles
to provide um Services uh pre-release
and as they come into the community um
uh case management servic
that one's required of every state to
implement um again the the history of of
children coming out of like an syc
setting you know dcyf setting um is that
you know the transitions into the
community are really important um points
in making sure they're connected to the
providers that they need making sure
that the preventative Services that they
should have received are are accounted
for and provided
um before they bake it back into the
community and then to make sure that
they're successfully reintegrating into
the
community um so you know just getting
back to this uh um see was on number
um
2025 was where I was talking started to
to talk about the adult program and 27
is the is the the program for youth um
and in between that is number 26 which
is a bill that um was actually passed by
both the house and the Senate um in two
different versions but basically the
same thing to provide um some
reimbursement to um ambul EMS calls
where there's treatment provided and
here again I think the experience um
that we saw from other states on this is
that while there'll be some cost to
reimbursing for those Services avoiding
um a situation where someone doesn't
have to go to an emergency room to get
cleared um that that's going to be a
savings to state but we didn't build in
the savings we just built in the
additional cost at this
point representative Neno for question
very quick question that that's uh the
uh number 19 and number 26 are are
linked or so they happened in different
years um those so actually prior to hb2
um there was some improvement in
ambulance rates and then the big lift up
to Medicare was um part of hp2 of 2023
and this was passed just this past
session
um yeah so it's part and parcel of the
same uh solution to an existing problem
which is basically uncompensated uh
um so I think um representative
Stringham for a question yeah can you
just um um give us the status of the uh
uh the waiver um to implement the
non-transport ambulance rates and uh and
what's been going on with that so the
one one where we're sorry my phone is
um the um we've done our research we
have the state plan drafted one of the
things we're clarifying is that the
House and Senate passed identical bills
with identical Appropriations and so I
think we're trying to clarify how that's
dealt with as a technical issue
um not sure if you have any update to
that yet no so that we need to we need
to get the funds I think um you know we
view this as a savings based on um you
know Kentucky is one of the states that
are actuary serves and that we so we'll
look to implement that as soon as we can
um okay so 27 and and and
um I think we're all dealing with the
the same those the waiver for um to be
able to provide that Community re-entry
benefit
um and they just requireed different
different uh vehicles to get the
authorities from CMS in place to be able
to do that
um then uh
29 um
as part of hb2 2023 there was a
component to ask the department to apply
for a waiver for presumptive eligibility
for people who would qualify for Home
and Community Based Services and the
concept here
um was
that um sometimes it takes a while for a
family to put together the documentation
to be able to meet all the eligibility
requirements so we're trying to avoid
here is situation where someone
decompensates while that eligibility
process is playing out to be able to put
certain services in place so that they
can stay in the home as opposed to being
institutionalized we were we filed that
2020 I'm
2024 um and um expect
um excuse me though that would have been
2023 sorry um September of 2023 where we
filed the waiver um it was part of our
larger 1115 waiver which was uh a
continuation of our um waiver for
institutional services for mental health
IMD and substance use disorder where the
state gets additional Federal funding
that um otherwise isn't generally paid
for without the waiver and those
benefits are intended to support the
state and the commity Based Services so
we we made that request with the renewal
CMS um
U had a lot with the outgoing
administration had a lot of waiver
requests that they were processing and
they said we believe we can approve this
we're following what Washington State um
largely had implemented they expected us
to see this come get an approval
sometime in
2025 um I don't have any new information
that it's different than that um but we
we're expecting that will come out the
other side again it's an an instance
where you know you do pay for certain
services but the actual cost of
avoidance of institutionalization is is
a saving so that the the waiver requires
us to um come in at no more than what it
costs us today and that's what the what
we mean by budget neutrality
representative Neno for a question so if
I understand this correctly it's a casew
worker that would look at us a given
situation on the presumptive thing and
say look uh this the circumstances here
are pretty high probability that the
they'll get the approval so we're uh
Expediting the delivery of the service
and then subject to uh at some point the
paperwork being filed and and getting
approved is that a correct description
of what what talking about here I'd say
generally I think that uh you're right
there' be a clinical person assessing
the the the situation to see what basic
Services need to be put in place to
avoid like we wouldn't place them in
certain settings that would be long-term
commitments for the state but we would
put in place maybe like a homemaker
service or make a a modification to
their home while waiting for other
things to come into play um okay thank
you
okay we made it through this the
services now we're on the home stretch
here
um so um number one under eligibility um
some of you may be familiar with the
acronym mode Medicaid for older adults
then we had the me which would for
people who are younger um but basically
um sometimes have greater income than um
would qualify them uh ordinarily but um
it makes sense when if they incur
certain level expenses to to provide
eligibility um so we create was created
that eligibility group um and then um in
um there was a uh provision to um add uh
premiums to that service
um that um we actually couldn't end up
implementing because of the the
conditions associated with the federal
Public Health Emergency of getting the
extra
6.2% um that you couldn't change your
eligibility requirements then as um
things went on um there was uh a
decision to not collect um the premiums
there and so that's that's kind of
what's happening in one and
two um number three is the um the the
last part of the mom R bill which was
the 12 month of continuous coverage
there are now 48 states that have the
same uh element in place and the two
states that um I think it was Wisconsin
and Arkansas are actively working and
putting it in place um in this current
um number four um is the um people who
have in andout coverage meaning that
unless they they generally wouldn't
qualify for Medicaid but if their
medical expenses are certain level they
do get um eligibility and um the
legislature has dealt with this um by
increasing um the allowances that um in
terms of what someone could have for
expenses like I think you know when
there was a huge increase in housing
costs it really the the criteria use
were were blown out of the water and I
think that um the legislature made
adjustments so that people who were
previously
qualifying um would continue to qualify
because the expenses had gone up so much
for individuals um and representative
Nano has a question yeah I just want to
come back to the um um the footnote here
I you know where're we're I'm trying to
understand the impact of covid and then
more importantly the question as I
recall it covid was over before it was
officially declared over or I mean how
did that impact so there's a date
specific when somebody said the
emergency is over even though it it you
know there might have been U statements
uh earlier on that it was over is that
yeah so you're you're pointing out a
little bit of uh tanglement kind of
situation so in January of uh 20 uh 20
actually on a retroactive basis the
president Trump at the time declared a
Federal Public Health Emergency related
to covid and part of that was to provide
States an enhanced Federal
match the at the time the the that
Federal Public Health Emergency had a
certain duration of time I think it was
90 days before it had to be renewed
again and so there was in the initial
couple years say 2021 there was this
situation where we're getting ready for
the federal Public Health Emergency to
end and then it got extended and then it
got extended then finally Congress acted
to um
provide a greater um level of of of
notice and they then beyond that they
came up with a specific date which was
March 31st of uh of
2023 but then the the fact that states
had um increased enrollment they didn't
immediately um you know in New Hampshire
we went from where we are today of
185,000 roughly to over
250,000 you know they expected that it
would take time for states to to
re start or in the case of New Hampshire
to we had we had kept a certain level of
activity going through the public health
emergency the whole time which is why we
were one of the earlier states to be
able to start and finish that unwind
effort but basically giving States a a
Runway to uh as they got back to regular
levels of enrollment uh additional
Federal funding and so in order to to
get those funds um that extra money
which is you know compared to the if you
will I'm being a little um flip here and
saying the pennies that would be
collected in premion versus the millions
that would be collected um by you know
not not uh violating the the
requirements um was was the decision
that was made um and that made a lot of
financial sense um and eventually that
that 6.2% kept on going down till it
ended um I think I think at a 2% level
in in
2020 December 2023 yes and
uh so that's that's kind of went on
there and then there was also another um
provision that came into play there was
um for to support Home and Community
Based Services which took a big hit
during the the pandemic um to um States
could get a onetime enhanced Federal
match of 10% their spending in Home and
Community Based Services that there was
also another condition that you had to
um you know keep eligibility the same um
and or you'd violate that that money so
the combination of factors I think made
it make sense not to really uh do this
and I think you know that these are not
people that are affluent it's just they
have ongoing medical expenses that may
be variable and so they're coming in an
off and on Medicaid
so so just a followup so net net all of
that confusion and extensions and
everything had a a a net negative or
positive impact on on including
including Moe becausee was you know part
and parcel of that if I understand the
footnote so I would say for New
Hampshire that um the additional Federal
match allowed us um to financially get
through the the federal Public Health
emergency pandemic period um in in an
okay Financial way from Medicaid
standpoint um we didn't have to um you
know other than under
the needing a little bit of liquor money
to additional liquor money to maintain
the the grant Advantage Program I mean I
can't even remember but hundreds of
millions of dollars that we took in um
in terms of that extra Federal match and
we may have had to to put that against
maybe 16 million or something to that
you so we're down to four five and six
here um on this page um so um in terms
of the the In-N-Out Medicaid while we we
made adjustments for
eligibility they were it was a onetime
adjustment then in 2023 they came back
and provided
um an adjustment that would occur um
January um of each year it began
actually U excuse
me January and then July then annually
thereafter um to provide some connection
to the uh Consumer Price Index changes
so that we don't end up in the same
position of 10 years not addressing the
eligib Billy levels and lots of people
not making it on who are in the same
place
um and
uh five
um yeah there's some um additional
protections of needing to serve uh
former foster care um regardless of
where you know if someone moved into
your state or someone from our state
moved into another state that we're
supposed to provide the Medicaid up to
age 20 till they turn
26 um number six is the um elimination
of of the premiums for um the mode that
earlier um number seven um is federally
part of the Consolidated appropriation
act um we
um we U had to provide 12 months of
continuous coverage for children that
was not
voluntary because our capitation rates
already reflected because people had
continuous enrollment already um during
the federal Public Health Emergency we
already had that cost built into our so
there was no new additional cost that we
had to account for in our capitation
rates because we already had that built
into our our base
um number eight was um basically
providing to lawfully residing women and
children the same um benefit as the
postpartum and continuous
coverage um This was um there's a a cost
total fund cost of uh 966 th000 but um
this one we believe has a enhanced
Federal match compared to uh just the
Federal um number nine representative
Neno with a question a very quick
question is there is there and this is
language related and number eight a
difference between lawfully residing and
domiciled there's a lot of um uh in
terms of the citizenship there's a lot
of different um levels of of of how
people are categorized there are
individuals who um could be entitled to
Medicaid benefits which are on a a
voluntary basis and then there are
people who who are not eligible until
they have a five-year period and then
there's other people who aren't eligible
at all um
this would probably be helpful if we
provide if you're really interested to
provide the specific citation of federal
law that with this group is because it's
uh you know the terminology sometimes is
important yes it is there's a lot of
nuances there and the choice of lawfully
residing as opposed to permanently
domiciled right or so this would cover
somebody visiting from another state um
this would be I think it's think of it
more as um someone who is a
noncitizen but is lawfully residing in
the
country based on Federal um rules it may
be that they're waiting for like a
refugee part of a refugee program or it
may not necessar necessarily be a
refugee program I think um there's a lot
of nuance this one I think if you're
interested I can give you the some
reading on on that to to help if you
want I'm sure it refers to federal law
where where these these terms are
defined exactly okay and and so the
choice of that
is I mean you can make some choices is
on what wording that use I
suppose ju just to clarify the the the
language lawfully residing children um
that that comes from from the hb2
provision from chapter 79 for Section
421 and in there it does site pursuant
to section 214 uh children's health
insurance program re reauthorization Act
of 2009 so that's the reason that you
see that language here we're trying to
tie it directly to the hb2 provision
that we're citing and the and then the
htb2 provision ties to federal law it
ties to the federal law exactly correct
thank
you and
um number nine um this is part of the
section um of the system of care for um
adult and aging population in terms of
um providing some
um or eligibility to to allow
individuals to have a little bit more
assets um to to not be considered um
there's also like the spousal
relationships there this was um again an
hb2 provision to um I think take into
account again how um costs and and and
being able to maintain yourself in the
community um and to be able to qualify
for services that um the ENT here was to
to try to be more rational about who is
getting eligibility and who is not um
and not putting people in a position
where they're so they have to go down so
far that it costs the state more to to
on so number 10 um was one of the ones
that uh the department um
um dealt with is that we had um during
the continuous eligibility we had
children that we had to maintain um who
might um have another source of
insurance as well and um from the an
audit that we had um in terms of
um whether these children could be
claimed at the 65% level or the 50%
level um we um to to put the state in
compliance we um use this eligibility
group so that um we would be in
compliance in terms of the federal match
level that we were drawing on these
children we do have third party
liability um activities to make sure
that uh Medicaid is the pay of Last
Resort um some of these children will
probably be the ones that would fall
into the the premiums if those are
adopted
um Madam
chair representative Neno for a question
so this is generally what I would think
of as a coordination of benefits um um
exercise yes um and who who has the
overall responsibility in DHHS for
managing the um coordination of Ben
benefits uh part of this so there's a
certain level of responsibility that's
within the um manage Care Organization
and then we also have um you met I think
with Meredith talo earlier I believe um
her Department of program Integrity um
is the party that works to make sure
that the for those who are in managed
care that those activities are happening
um as well as other um types of cost
avoidance activities that you would
otherwise um do in an insurance program
um and then there you know there's a
small element of our our Medicaid
Program that are fee for service still
and and then we have the responsibility
in the department for that so we we
Outsource we basically Outsource that
piece of it to uh managed care
facilities and then there's a the audit
require I mean I guess what's happening
on the quality section is it's uh uh
qual but in between that who provides
the oversight so so that's um meris
Department the program Integrity to make
sure that um we actually monitor them
very closely on that activity because
manag Care organizations sometimes
that's not their strongest suit um right
and we actually build into our manage
care contract a certain level of
performance on that activity whether
they meet it or not we're going to take
a credit against what we pay them in cap
reputation um so there's an incentive
for them to perform and we're also
looking to strengthen our own
capabilities in that area in terms of
doing more data matching to to uh to
strengthen that that whole activity even
further we think there's still
you um and then
uh
see the last one um which doesn't have a
number on it number would be otherwise
number 11 um I think this was another
action to um to provide um an this was
update that's a lot to digest M chairman
and you presented it very well I'm in
awe of how you can um do this almost on
the Fly and uh that we're really
fortunate to have you at the helm here
in New Hampshire uh dur
medical equipment or supplies uh what
percentage of that uh is determined and
plans to control that so that would be
known as
um durable medical equipment is the is
the correct uh uh uh tme correct for the
abbreviation of that um so in terms of
um within the Managed Care Program um
there's a requirement to provide needed
Dural medical equipment um and that
would be based on uh patients condition
um the
uh the legislature I think has um
um provided um a change in the
percentage on um I think in the last
session from 80% to 90% of the um of
um um appliances that more like in the
orthopedic space if you will that to
support um Rehabilitation and and such
but it is built into our our our program
um today and um it's it's one of the
areas that's a little bit challenging
because in providing DME a lot of the
things that you provide are
Commodities um meaning that there's a
national market and um you can buy it at
a very low cost but there's also
component of um sometimes going to the
house and providing that service as well
to instruct or to apply and so we've
been um balancing in the Medicaid
Program um the market Forces versus you
know needing to make sure like the post
office that you can deliver to any
community in the state and so what we're
we we tried to do um back in our second
procurement of the Managed Care Program
was to provide a floor to which
um uh reimbursement could could happen
and um there was a $3 million investment
made at that time Managed Care Program
and
think the DME providers are still
struggling out there a bit on this
because um you know they have um the
Personnel cost and and the
transportation cost to serve all parts
of the state you know it's if you're
located in downtown Manchester and
serving Manchester is different than you
know up in colbrook right in terms of
serving the the North country and so um
I think this is an area that we you know
spend a lot of time on I think you know
we in terms of the appropriation that we
have to work with we're doing the best
we can I'm sure you may be hearing from
DME providers that they would like like
more I think you did address part of
that issue with the appliances that um
that went up to 90% of Medicare um but
it's it is a a challenging area in terms
of making sure that um the state is a a
good purchaser um but
also you know there are costs for
servicing the small areas it's
and what we want to make sure is that
the whole state can be served I'm not
sure if there was more to what your
question was but that's that was good um
I have another question related uh to
another service that wasn't mentioned
but Homebase dialysis uh what is the
Readiness or the interest in that and
cost and transportation if you could
discuss that sure um we do cover
homebased dialysis today I know that um
the chairman had mentioned to us about
um a technology that is potentially
coming out that uh would differentiate
between what we do today um it's we're
we're going to be looking into that uh
based on his request uh to to do that
but we do a lot of dialysis is picked up
by Medicare that PE and Stage renal
disease that usually the tenure on on
Medicaid for dialysis usually picked up
by Medicare because they qualify that
way but we do have some people that
don't qualifies and but uh we do provide
all forms of dialysis that are currently
available that the newest one that was
brought to our attention where we need
to take a look into
that great thank
you looks like we are approaching 11
o'clock just as a time check uh no rush
um we're about halfway through your
slides and of course then we have um
House Bill two provision
so um however you'd like to proceed so I
think the next part to get to the house
bill to because I'm sure you want to
spend time on that um the the next uh we
were left the slide deck at uh onto page
eight so this is in response to a
request to share the waivers the state
plan
amendments that are in place today and
basically 8 n
our our water water in place when it
began um and if it ended um there are a
few that have ended
um well not a few but um one at least
that has ended the the co Health covid
Public Health Emergency um 11:15 waiver
ended um as did the disaster waiver um
so um this is the list of of of individ
of the different
exceptions to ordinarily covered
services that Medicaid provides um then
on um page 10 um the page number didn't
come out on that one sorry um is how it
all sort of uh this another
representation of what's on the prior
page is what we call our waiver wheel um
everything evolves
around what we call the state plan um
those are the required services and the
optional services that that the state
has adopted and then when you're asking
for an exception to ordinary things um
like the ones in pink um we talked about
earlier the the personal care services
to be able to that's ordinarily you need
a special state plan Amendment called um
a 1915 J which is at the top uh to be
able to do this is just a in terms of
the things that the Division of Medicaid
services we work with all the other
divisions and getting these things in
place but we don't necessarily oversee
them dayto day like um let's see the
inhome support waiver would be a good
example of that that provides you know
services to U severely disabled children
typically in their homes that their
other parts of the department typically
would be in long-term services and
support and special medical needs but
you know our role as the division of
Medicaid is to provide
you know first and foremost the the
health insurance component what you
would think of the Medicaid Program and
then to support the rest of the
department in um their interactions with
CMS to get exceptions U to provide
certain Services um or waivers to
provide certain Services as well as the
financing component and the financing
component um is not all us either we um
interact with u Nathan's team and in
terms of the federal claiming um if you
will we're sort of the the policy
expertise and
financing understanding and the actual
making sure that we do it right and
claiming is really under Nathan's group
and managing portions of of this chart
go to different programers like kacha
Fox's division would be um one uh the
the DD waiver you know is uh Melissa
Hardy um over sees you know that
division so this gives you a picture of
everything we have um and kind of what I
have to have a certain my division has
to have a certain level of interaction
with but we don't control everything
that happens in these spaces but when
when CMS has an issue they look to the
Medicaid director as a single point of
contact to the state and um it's really
a partnership and working with other
parts of the department um and you know
trying to meet needs and and when needs
are for particular populations are are
special that's where these um Pieces
come into play representative priest for
a question followed by representative
walner thank you Madame Vice chairman
back on page nine the last item on
waivers 1135 disaster
waivers it came into existence in 2020 I
mean I'm sorry 2020 and it ended in 23
can you give us just some
a
brief sure what that was so at at the
very beginning like March of 2020 um you
know there were concerns that our
hospitals were going to get overrun okay
um we were it was a permission to um be
able to work outside of normal um
conditions and meeting like you know if
we were going to use an Armory to or to
to be able to do testing outside of the
conventional means it was basically
those things that could get
flexibilities and still receive a
Medicaid match um that didn't comply
with with what would be normal times um
that's why it's called a disaster waiver
you know states that have hurricanes and
tornadoes deal with this all the time
this is the only one I've dealt with in
my tenure hopefully it'll be the only
one that yeah so you have a kind of a
plan in place for this and even though
it's not being utilized now it could be
utilize if we have something like the
sea sea levels Rising on the coast and
at our communities yeah so we would have
to go back and there are different
specific authorities you can ask for um
like the think of the wildfires that
were in California like some of the
hospitals that were maybe destroyed in
that or other healthare facilities you
know may sometimes you have a a region
but this one was a Statewide kind of
situation um um but basically we have a
a contact at CMS that says you know we
can reach out to and um get special
exceptions to things that ordinarily
they wouldn't pay for because they're
not delivered in the standard way okay
thank
you thank you um so most of these have
ending dates on them yes what happens
when we come to the end or get close to
the end do you need to reapply yes um
like we for example in the sud SMI 1115
waiver um we we applied for an extension
because it would otherwise have ended
and so um we had to make application so
for um each of these wavers there's
probably been a renewal particularly if
you look at some of the dates that go
back um like the DD waiver you know
originated in 1987 which is on page um
eight um the second one from the bottom
and the choices for Independence waiver
was 1984 so either typically they're
either two or fiveyear renewals um and
uh sometimes you need an amendment uh to
a waiver if something is changing in
them like you know I think there's
discussion out there about you know
criteria for CFI that you know if you
make certain eligibility changes um you
just can't do that c blanch you have to
um well I guess the last informational
thing was um the last two informational
things here um there was a question
about how our Dental rates compare um on
page 11 um I think the third bullet is
kind of what I would focus in on is that
um when we did this study with our
actuary in
2023 that uh our Medicaid fees were 76%
% of the commercial allowed charges as
opposed to if you looked at build
charges they're 46% of the build charges
um you know there's typically you'll see
in hospital bills and and other provider
bills that the bill charges are often
higher than the allowed charges and so
we measured ourselves in a couple
different ways
um that's really just informational I'm
not I don't remember who had this
specific question but there's any more
detail
need now moving back to um some forms of
Eligibility this I think relates to a
question that came up earlier like what
is the current enrollment um in Medicaid
as of March 3rd um a point in time
enrollment measurement um our granted
Advantage Programs at 59
um you know we're about 8,500 more than
we were back in March of 2020 I think I
shared some of the
reasons um for that um the standard
program is within 811 of where we were
in March of 2020 um so that's pretty
close to where we were then and then you
know the total enrollment is about 4.4%
higher than we were in March of 2020 in
part if you look at continuous coverage
for children continuous coverage for um
pregnant women um you know part of that
is built into that but we're we're
largely back uh if you look at the chart
below the the numbers that are on the
far left by eligibility group is what we
were at
177,00 if you look at the grand total in
March of 2020 today um we're at 185
139 and you can see how the various
eligibility groups um have uh grown or
or not um over time compared to
different um the the percent change
since um 2020 March of 2020 or you can
look at the percent change to the far
right from the end of the federal Public
Health Emergency where we started the
unwind
um then on page uh 13 this is something
I um sorry sorry representative tarki
for a question where up above in the
adult groups is the um um postpartum
extension to 12 months so those
non-disabled adults so that would be
some of them are are in the adult
expansion group um that's where they
begin um and they could be in in um they
could be in the other
uh
um other non-disabled adults those those
are probably be the two
places that we would find them I think
the the um the federal benefit of
providing an enhanced Federal match on
them a lot of them would either um be
like they would have been in granted
Advantage they got pregnant as an
example they otherwise after their
pregnancy would only have the 60 days of
coverage now they have 12 months we if
you interested in more detail on that I
can um give you some follow no I'm just
trying to connect the dots between you
know that sliver of of the population
that got the extended care and the num
the bottom line numbers of how many
people are being served and so where
that growth came so I think in terms of
the the granted Advantage we're talking
about hundreds not thousands that's what
I thought yeah small yeah it's probably
under well under a thousand well
okay can I ask one more question digging
into the children children's numbers a
little bit yes um the can you speak to
the increase of
26.6% in um chip kids and and what's
behind that sort of significant increase
yeah in terms of
um I think
the the economic circumstances of the
state that you know when you look at
um U the the eligibility for chip Right
In terms of the the federal poverty
limit to which gets them into that level
I think you know New Hampshire has one
of the lowest poverty levels and while
we have poverty and people in severe
poverty I think in terms of generally
our our communities are doing better
than than National comparisons and I
think what has happened is we've seen M
some migration because of increased with
the labor shortage some of the increased
wages that have happened you know people
who were maybe you
know some of the basic jobs now required
paying $15 an hour or more that I think
we've seen some of the individuals who
qualify for children have been pushed up
as wages have improved in the state that
that's my that's my theory on it um that
so we haven't necessarily expanded
coverage for children no that would
translate to a one qu% increase the the
only expansion we did was how long we
covered them for which is 12 months
starting in January 2024 um 12 months of
continuous cover so my conclusion to
that is we just have more kids living in
poverty in the state um I think
actually we have some statistics on that
we could probably provide to you I think
when um trying to remember here if we
one of your questions and I think if we
um David I think it's the last slide
right
yeah so this is um some statistics on um
looking over time um the uninsurance
rate with children and poverty levels I
think one of the question was to us was
um U you know what we've seen in terms
of the three bullets on the far right
hand side conclusions this is the very
handout so we've seen the the lowest
income children that we've seen a a 91
um has decreased 91% over the last 10
years in terms of their uninsurance rate
um then another question that we had was
for
the um children that are potentially um
could meet the eligibility criteria um
who aren't currently enrolled we um
we the demographer Mr got uh PhD got Le
who does Consulting for the state helped
us with this information here um
there're about 11,500 kids one of the
things that um my deputy director
reminded me this morning is that for
families who um have a choice of
Medicaid or um potentially ACA coverage
for the family there are instances where
um that the subsidies that are available
it makes sense that not when you look at
a single child but on a whole family
level um to to choose ACA coverage over
Medicaid so I can't tell you how many
people are in that world but there are
instances where when you look at from a
family perspective if everybody's going
to need um a certain type of coverage
particularly ACA coverage that they may
not choose to go on Medicaid um because
on a whole economic basis for the family
it's cheaper for them to go that way um
and then
um the last bullet
um that uh sort of I guess ties to this
there approximately um you know 86,500
kids enrolled in the Medicaid and and um
98,000 kids in New Hampshire who are at
or below in families of 323 per of
poverty so we do cover a pretty large
percentage of the what what are the
potentially eligible um you know we have
the fifth highest eligibility level at
um 323 they're you know um about half
the states stop at 25% or less of
poverty um you know New Hampshire has
had a long history of providing um I
think higher eligibility for children um
I think if you go way back to the New
Hampshire Healthy Kids standpoint there
we were at 300% of poverty at the time
um so I think you know when you look at
you know long-term costs for State you
know taking care of
children typically less expensive than
than adults if you do the right
preventative Services um in the long run
I think you you have lower costs and um
you know we're among the not to say we
don't have our issues as a state but we
rank in the usually in the top five or
better in terms of you know health
status of our population and you know I
think we get pretty high marks overall
on our children again that's not to say
that there aren't pockets of areas that
we still need to work on but I think
that's something you could be proud of
as a legislature and us as Medicaid unit
that um I think we're doing a lot of
good work um with children and as is the
rest of the Department of Health and
Human Services No Doubt thank you for
sure I just there's two things I would
like to point out and I know I want to
save as much time for hb2 as we could
13 I have an ey appointment next week
for new glasses so definitely need them
um one of the things that we started to
do during the federal Public Health
Emergency was we started to do Outreach
directly through the
department and through our
mcos um during the continuous coverage
period to say do you still need
Medicaid are you still a resident of the
state and just in the past year um by
doing that survey work um both through
the mcos and the department that um
people who um who you know when
contacted um and said do you still need
the coverage you know there were almost
6,000 individuals who told
us they don't need it anymore um there
are people who move out of New Hampshire
um you know we look at death records to
make sure we're not covering people who
aren't living um and then you know
there's other people who are are not
requesting it any further so I'm just
saying in a one-year period in terms of
making sure that we're not paying for
people who don't need the coverage or
are no longer eligible in state that
we're this is something that we weren't
doing pre- pandemic this is something
that we started during the pandemic and
are continuing um if I went back the
year before the number over the year
year period that we had done that as
well what I'm trying to say here is I
think we're trying to be conscientious
about not paying for
services and using dollars where they're
not needed um because I know that
dollars are are are precious
particularly this this budget that we're
continuing to do this work and intend to
to continue to do it and I just sort of
proud of that that we're doing that very
important thank you for the slide the
the next two slides kind of go together
um the the one with the bar graph uh
page 14 is the expart rate um what expar
means is that the department has enough
information to renew someone without um
an individual like we have access to um
income records or asset records or so
forth that during the federal Public
Health Emergency and the unwind
period there were special
um um
flexibilities that states were given to
deal with the huge backload backlog of
redeterminations we had while we got
30,000 done during the public health
emergency there were 230,000 to catch up
on um so um we you know a lot of these
flexibilities were intended to make sure
that particularly in the the elderly the
home and commit based people that where
there's um you have to Prov paperwork
that there are periods of where some
people who became on Medicaid never had
to do a redetermination then you had
people that you know during the public
health emergency may not have kept up
with their financial records because
they didn't need to because they didn't
redetermining end
um June 30th and so page 15 is a chart
um that um is just an example of the
month of March of 2025 I'm going to jump
down to the bottom give you the the
punchline for you know to save time here
but by those flexibilities going away
there are TW over
2500 um cases and over 3,000 individuals
that would have gone
expart um who won't and I'm you know the
reason I bring up this concern is not is
in terms of as you look at the the
eligibility area Karen Hebert's unit in
particular in terms of the the Staffing
that she has available um the the the
resources for for it and and uh um and
such that and call center that we're
going to get a lot more calls we're
going to get um have to do a lot more
case workk than we than we've been doing
and I'm just concerned that we provide
good service to um to making people
eligible when they're eligible and um so
I think that's just a draw your
attention this for two reasons in terms
of one you know we are trying to um
reduce the roles where where it's
appropriate to do so um but that by
ending all these flexibilities it's and
with a hiring freeze we've got a big
challenge ahead of us here that where
from a constituent service standpoint
you know the number one issue that
that I hear about you know our our U
eligibility the time it takes to get
eligibility um particularly when it's
not just an income based eligibility and
there are factors that are related to
what people can do and produce for their
records They have a responsibility to to
um to provide information you know if
they have a trust we have to get the
trust document make sure it qualifies um
but this is this is a big issue I think
to you know when you think about the
type of calls you may get
um as legislators in terms of you know
I'm not I need the service and I'm not
eligible yet this this is my concern for
you in this area representative Nano for
a question yeah thank you madam chair
and thank you mrman um back to uh slide
13 yes so I want to make sure I
understand this so This the survey or
the questions that that you're asking um
originate with DHHS and then the um
mcos uh administer or solicit responses
from the recipient uh pull that the
individual MCO
manages uh does the
MCO uh take it on themselves to report
um uh you know people that don't need it
anymore or what's the what's the process
look like there yeah so we actually I
actually could produce a report behind
this these numbers these are aggregated
by all by we track each month by each
MCO the level that that's happening um
we also do when we see particularly
children when we see children clo we're
making outbound calls to families by the
mcos to to to make sure that they've
gotten the paperwork that they aware of
what's going on um and for those that we
see that have uh a clinical history or
or are you know under treatment and we
have our clinical team um within the
Medicaid division make outbound calls
after the mcos have made their calls to
try to make sure that someone
particularly children that are
closing that we're not that that we've
done everything we possibly can do and
we're going to redouble our efforts in
this area um because you know I still
see the closure rate um for people who
end up closing particular children is
higher than I'd like to see it and um
you know I was just talking this morning
before we came into this meeting about
you know what's let's uh we need to
prepare the the Medicaid Community about
the the end of the um the the U
flexibilities the the that we have that
are going to end in June and we need to
sort of look at changing our strategies
up we've done different things like uh
on our noticing to change the color of
the paper to try to draw attention and
so we've had the yellow paper which was
you know caution your your eligibilities
coming towards renewal then we had um
the pink paper which is like a like a
red that you know it's going to close
and then we have blue paper that we send
out for notices we do both electronic
and paper and that saying it it's it's
not if it's blue it's not too late to
renew meaning and then we're looking at
um this Final Phase of warning people
about the change and eligibility
criteria we're going to use um purple
paper to you know just to get people to
notice what we're sending to them um and
to try to get action and it's amazing
you know what we did there got picked up
nationally and number of different other
states you know use that technique too
and um and you know it's important that
you know anybody who's really eligible
we want to make sure stays eligible
those who are not we we we have to close
them because they don't meet the
criteria on the other hand we also try
to work with um the The Navigators that
are um and we try to make referrals to
to help people get to the right place um
where they might be able to get coverage
representative Daniels for a
question thank you referring to the
chart on page 13 we know how much and
benefits might have been paid out to
people prior to February 24 that were
not
eligible I don't I think that if I'm can
make sure I'm understanding your
question I think what you're saying is
that there were individuals who no
longer really qualified and that the
state uh because of the continuous
coverage needed to keep them covered um
we do we knew that
um at the end of March there were about
30,000 individuals who based on the
information we had um were likely over
income and we um we closed all of them
that we could we had to give them a
chance to let us know if the information
that we had um wasn't accurate um you
know income sometimes it can lags in in
in the public sources that we can access
um and the information that they provide
but you know before we planned our
unwind um to we had done analytics on
the the people who were still eligible
and we looked at those where we had a
good sense that they were over income we
closed those first then we we went to
granted Advantage you know secondarily
because again a lot of the what we see
is typically a short tenure there some
people have been on granted Advantage
for a number of years and so what we try
to do is structure the unwind so that
the most vulnerable people had the most
time to react to the the unwind like the
people in nursing homes the people in
home and commun Based Services because
they were likely you know they're likely
to remain eligible their income probably
didn't change whereas you know certain
populations did and so we protected
children the longest then a little bit
longer the homeing community base and
then the nursing home IND individuals
and we protected them by because what
what feds were telling to States is we
didn't want you to do everything all at
one time because you would create a
workload that would be like a a large
distribution they wanted you to have uh
at the end to end up with a a
distribution that you could handle on a
regular basis so you didn't have delays
in moving people off or bringing people
on and so we did do a lot of work in
that space to figure out what we should
do and when we should do it um so there
are I don't have an exact dollar figure
but I think the the best thing I could
give you there is I think that at the
time that it ended there were 30,000
individuals approximately I believe that
we were able to close right up front and
and uh those that that we did close we
did um plenty of work ahead of time to
make sure they were aware of it that
they had an opportunity to let us know
if we didn't have good information
and for those people who did nothing and
never responded to us we even had uh
developed um we were the only state in
the nation to do this but to be able to
connect that um they had a chance their
case was referred to the the
um s CIO which is the the uh agency
within HS that that oversees the ACA
coverage that um they they check to see
if they would be eligible for ACA
coverage and they would have an
opportunity to to hear about that so I
think um we try to both be um Humane in
terms of you know the people that would
have challenges to give them the longest
time those people who are probably more
able-bodied if you will that we did
those individuals up front um and we
where we couldn't keep them eligible we
at least try to give them referrals to
you know options that were available
elsewhere um we do know that a good
number of the people who left Medicaid
um we did a a
survey um with a a a company that um was
trying to test an approach to uh um I
think we surveyed about 5,000
individuals who had closed and lo found
out that I think it was like over 60% of
them had found another source of
insurance um and so I do think that
we've you know I'm not saying we were
the best state at doing this but I think
we were among the best in terms of of
doing um that whole unwind process and
we put a lot of thinking into it
representative Nano for a question yeah
a quick question on that and this is uh
maybe you know not not a totally fair
question but what's Your Gut feel for
what the trend line uh on table on page
13 going forward would look like given I
think given the experience that you've
had and what you've just described in
terms terms of the the detailed process
that uh you go through um I think we're
going to continue the process I think it
you know the the period of the last 12
months was sort of the tail end of any
unwinding we had to do so I you know I
think anywhere between 8,000 and 10,000
is you know realistic that circumstances
change as I mentioned in the grand
Advantage Program the tenure there is
less than a year um on
average so going forward the trend line
is is down in terms of down a little bit
because I think we've narrowed the the
we've we're now doing annual um
redeterminations as opposed to
previously we had because of federal
Public Health Emergency we had some
people three to four years before they
15 so 15 was the one that I pointed out
that um the result of the end of the the
the federal Flex flexibilities that this
is just an example of the month of March
that we've modeled out to give you a
sense that the workload for the
eligibility folks is going to increase
um that if we had the PO if we if the
e14 authorities the flexibilities had
ended in this this month there would be
redetermination as opposed
to systemic which is that's 3,000 for
just that month you know every other
month could be you know in that same
range um we're we're figuring that
there's going to
be compared to the last four years
between 20 and 25% more cases to have
more um
human intervention in order to determine
eligibility that the system won't be
able to to do it alone
um and uh so that's that's where I'm
concerned about from
a from a constituent service standpoint
the the issue of not um delaying people
who are eligible because we're dealing
with people to find out whether they're
eligible or not that that collision
between the additional workload is it's
you know what I'm trying to do is you
know share up front that we're going to
be the eligibility team which is not my
unit but a unit that I depend on is
going to be under a lot more stress with
respect to the workload um that they
have to contend with it's it's
effectively we do about 12,000
13,000 um of these redeterminations a
month if if if 3,000 is the average it's
it's really like getting 3 months of
extra work to do over what we've been
years
um slides 18 uh excuse me 161 17 are uh
ones that we shared with you previously
but the the flesh car line um I think we
had provided last time was sort of the
aggregate of what happened between March
of 23 and July of 24 in terms of um
successfully
completing a
redetermination those people who were um
not part of the protected group meaning
that weren't under continuous coverage
renewed at a much higher rate than those
that were in the the the protected group
and um what we did here was just give
you a little bit more of a historical
look at it back to August the 24 month
by month but the number of people who
are retaining Medicaid Eligibility at
you know in the '90s is you know pre
pandemic it was like in the 70s or 60s
um and the concern you know that people
who are eligible um with with the the
loss of those flexibilities and the
increased workload that um we'll see
more churn um churn is okay if it's
intended because they're not really
eligible but we don't want churn because
work and I think um if if you're okay
um representative that we'd be ready to
tackle hb2 if if you want to get to that
or take any more questions thank you I
appreciate that and again this
presentation will be found online on our
material page both from the LBA website
and the department of administrative
Services my thought at this point is to
take a five minute recess when we return
start through the provisions of House
Bill 2 until approximately noon come
back at 12:
45 um I'd like to take up House Bill 71
at
1 um and again these are just my
thoughts that should be brief and then
have you resume if necessary after that
does that make sense to you that's
whatever you your pleasure will be here
your thoughts representative tar I just
want to clarify what I heard um I guess
I'm questioning the coming back at 12:45
if we are noticed for 1: p.m. are you
intending for Mr Lipman to go for 15
minutes then stop then one and I and I
also just want to clarify that the um uh
my caucus actually or my side actually
has a caucus a lunchtime caucus from 12:
to hopefully
1 so those 15 minutes is what I'm just
questioning okay in that case because of
the caucus why don't we break from 12 to
1 that's perfect
okay okay all right we're in recess for
great
e
okay we'll resume after what was just a
five minute brief recess this is a work
session continued on the division of
Medicaid continued from February 21st
for those who want to go back and watch
YouTube the part one was February 21st
for division
3 so our plan now is we're going to go
to 12 noon we're going to start through
the provisions relative to Medicaid in
house build 2 I believe that starts on
page 48 eight am I correct of House Bill
2 uh we'll recess then for an hour we'll
come back at 1:00 at 1:00 is scheduled
and has been duly noticed a work session
on House Bill
71 so we'll do that uh if we need uh Mr
Lipman and Mr White to come back after
that house bill 71 work session to
continue the discussion on Medicaid
specifically the provisions of House
Bill 2 will do that so that's where we
are that's the lay of the land today uh
so gentlemen uh thank you again for
always making yourselves available
especially a reschedule a continuation I
should say a continuation of Medicaid
discussion and we'll begin when you're
ready I have House Bill two in front of
me great so uh again Nathan white Chief
Financial Officer with the Department of
Health and Human Services what may be
helpful for members is if you look back
at the presentation uh from the Friday
from the week before um slide 21
detailed the the specific reductions or
assumed reductions in the governor's
budget and it may be helpful just to
have that open as we go through the hb2
provisions just so I I can certainly
narrate you know this is a $3.3 million
assumption for each year but it may be
helpful just to have the members have
that open so for future reference in
case it was needed I'm sorry you said SL
31 21 21 that we heard on February 21
makes it easy to remember yes thank you
for that the Friday afternoon session
okay so in the uh hb2 as introduced um
beginning on page 48 as uh co-chairman M
money had indicated the first section
that I will draw your attention to is
section 89 this is The Graduate medic
medical education payments um this is a
a program that's being suspended for the
bium if the if the committee sought to
uh fund this we would need additional
General funds it has been funded in a
number of
Bia um the second provision there is uh
section 90 it's on line 26 page 48 this
is suspension of catastrophic Aid
payments to hospital uh this is similar
this has not been funded in a number of
Bia and additional General funds would
be needed to fund that program section
91 on line 30 is Medicaid to schools
program fiscal committee approval of
supplemental funding um this has been in
effect for a couple of Bania this is an
hb2 provision that's just been chapter
law this allows the department to accept
additional federal funds for the
Medicaid to schools program uh just as a
reminder going back to the conversation
that we had there is no direct general
fund cost to the state for this this
simply allows the department
um to accept the federal funds in the
event that the budgeted amounts exceed
uh what we what we are appropriated um
we have not had to use this provision um
since since it's Inception but it is
something that uh we did originally
request in our agency budget and form e
to
continue uh moving on to page 49 section
92 um this provision here this is the
carry forward provision that that we
have discussed this is um some some
states have this we've had this uh in
hb2 since the pandemic and what this
allows the department to do is carry
forward funds from one Bia to the next
under state law I think it's under rs9
uh any general funds would naturally
lapse back to the general fund coffers
given the ups and downs in Medicaid
relative to enrollment Trends and things
of that nature we work with our
actuaries to to
what those would be but there there are
always potential changes um what this
does is by allowing the funds to be
carried forward um you actually see a
net reduction in the total General funds
that are needed in the Medicaid budget
um in state fiscal year 26 and
um and from there we move forward a
couple and and just one key provision
there is the effective date it needs to
be effective June 30th 2025 otherwise
those funds would
lapse and now if you yes representative
tarki for a question in a scenario where
perhaps the governor doesn't sign the
happens that's one of those uh
situations where we have to work through
it with the advice of our
Council um to interpret the laws as they
stand it would kind of depend on what
the continuing resolution specified so
if it specified that all provisions of
law continue or if it made reference to
to the existing hb2 then perhaps those
funds could be carried forward and they
wouldn't lapse um it would really be
dependent upon the language in in the in
the C okay yeah that's what I thought
okay thanks I appreciate the
question
okay so moving forward
to going to move a couple Pages forward
here I believe the next relevant
provision is uh
102 this is the um there's a there's a
corresponding Bill uh that's currently
moving through the process this this is
this provision 102 and 103 this was
relative to the department being able to
purchase brand name drugs there's
currently a statutory prohibition on us
purchasing brand named drugs where
there's a generic equivalent
um on slide 21 of the presentation from
the 21st you will see the the cost
savings there it it come it's it's under
the preferred drug list savings it's
$930,000 assumed Savings in the first
year and then two almost $3 million in
the second year and that's the result of
um us being able to increase the rebate
Revenue because there's higher rebates
on the brand name drugs I'm going to let
Henry jump in here so that it's
basically acquiring drugs at the lowest
net cost I think there was a question
that representative Daniels had early on
this does not add it makes it lower both
for the state and the federal government
um which is um not the usual typical
thing I think also too that this is
something that you'll see we go from the
900 to the 2 million we feel that
there's even further savings over time
to be had so I think this provision
would be you know helpful not only for
this banian but the next by am to so we
one representative tki for question
thank you I think you we asked this
question last week but I need you to
remind me why is the savings like rolled
in only 900,000 the first by year by
name and then it really ramps up yeah
because um people are currently on on
drugs right that so you don't want to
disrupt someone who may be successfully
being treated on
patients plus also program Plus getting
Physicians um and the mcos sort of
geared up for this so it's just I think
a matter of um reasonable expectation to
make a transition from where we are
today to a new place um and that's
that's basically uh that's where that's
coming from is that it's going to take
something to implement it you know for
example if the the budget's not signed
into law till um you know the end of
June or even you know into July right
that gotcha IE what you're saying yeah
getting the whole system set up and
running okay sorry thanks no
worries great so moving forward if you
turn to page
51 and section 107 Department of Health
and Human Services Pharmacy copay
Medicaid Program so this this is the uh
this is the provision directing the
department uh to establish um
prescription drug co-pays up to in an
amount of
$4 in the um the spreadsheet from the
March 21st presentation you'll see that
there's an assumed uh total Savings of
about $1.5 million in each state fiscal
Federal okay the next section just below
that section 108 uh Department health
and human Human Services Medicaid
Managed Care
um this provision here this directs the
department to complete no more than one
Medicaid or one Medicaid rate filing
each year with CMS and how that results
in $500,000 of general fund savings in
total across the bium is basically we
would need to amend our contract um to
reduce the price limitation to to
capture those
savings M representative tarki for a
question thanks I'm sorry getting very
nitpicky but trying to understand it in
section 107 when we talk about the
pharmacy copay when we spoke about this
a little over a week ago you stated this
would only apply to people who um do not
fall under the premium structure and
while I Z that's correct yes if they're
paying a premium they would not be
subject to that so I see this language
is pretty straightforward but does not
show that exception on the premium
language does
it I think we're we're covered by the
fact that to to under CMS rules and
regulations that we have to monitor that
we don't exceed the 5% and without the
reason that we're just keeping it simple
of Premium no co- payment or or no
premium co-payment is that we don't have
to make significant it changes and
absorb all our savings if you will by
making all those it changes some states
would have both premiums and cost
sharing but we're just not configured
that way I understand that and and that
makes sense to me I guess I'm just
trying to see where in this language of
the hb2 it makes that delineation that
those who pay a co-pay won't have to pay
the or those who pay the premium won't
have to pay the co-pay because the way I
read this right
everyone I I see your point I I think um
that you know the if you wanted to amend
something language there that that's how
we intend to act and how we intend to
remain compliant with CMS regulations is
not to do both because we don't have a
mechanism to track both co-pays and um
but I guess I'm just want to make sure
that there's Clarity because I'm I hear
you trying to protect the people who are
okay excellent any other questions on
Section 107 or
108 okay um the next section line 32 uh
section 109 the Department of Health and
Human Services New Hampshire granted
Advantage healthc Care Program premiums
established um this establishes the
premiums and you will see on slide 21
there's there's an assumed uh Savings of
approximately $12 million to the state
and this is not a direct impact to the
Department's budget
this is an indirect impact to the
Department's budget through savings that
are um
or you will see an increased uh profit
margin within the Liquor Commission as a
result of this because there there's the
assumption that those liquor funds will
not be needed to be transferred over to
granted Advantage so you won't see the
direct impact within division 3 um my
assumption is that division one is
talking about this uh and they if
they're not they certain certain should
be uh just because that's where they're
going to that's where you're going to
see the benefit because of the uh the
funding mechanism for the granted
Advantage program and you're you were
referring to section 109 of House Bill 2
correct okay representative walner for a
question yes I sure you went over this
on Friday but how many people do you
think this will affect it's um think a
little over 10,000 is my recollection
that was 11,000 yeah 11,000
11,000 thank
you okay out of the
59 excellent uh so moving forward to
page 52 uh section 110 on line one
Department of Health and Human Services
Medicaid Program premiums
established um so the this is the
directive to Institute premiums um
within the the chip program for uh
families at at or above 255 of the
federal poverty limit there's an assume
Savings of uh $3.3 million in general
funds in state fiscal year 26 and $1
million in state fiscal year 27 I if you
the yeah no okay I mean I think that
that's we're assuming that that one has
to
um because of the continuous coverage
requirements for children that is
there's going to be a rolling in of that
um that that uh premium for for families
and that you know we do expect that we
are going to and I know there are
questions out there in terms of what our
all polic is going to be around um we
haven't got to be able to put that all
together yet but you know um would
represent to you that um we're going to
need to be able to address people who
are in treatment that we're not going to
want to cut off and that we want to
interact with CMS so that we don't
design something that uh that that isn't
going to work from them compliantly and
we want to make sure that we're working
from our end to make sure that we're
being humanely implementing the policy
um so I think the it's going to take a
little bit of work to to get everything
synchronized but there are certain
children that we can't charge premiums
for anybody below that
25% there are other potential IAL
children that have are in special
eligibility groups that are excluded as
well I think we we're estimating about
8,600 children with would be subject to
this just by historic terms I went back
and looked at
um uh the healthy kids Corporation um
and just
coincidentally um there were I think
8,600 kids about that time paying
premiums so it's I'm not saying they're
Apples to Apples but they're at least in
the same category fruit in terms of the
number of people to be affected by
premiums and
co-pays representative walner for a
question so I was wondering if you had
would any consideration be given to a
family where maybe the children were are
on um Medicaid but the parent is
purchasing health insurance for
themselves I actually spoke to a woman
the other day who is purchasing for
herself
um a Marketplace product and I think she
said she was paying
$252 a month for it and the children are
on Medicaid now because I'm sure she
falls within this category now she's
going to have to probably face
another $2 to $300 for the
children this puts this family is really
going to be
paying a large amount are we going to
look at anything if they're already
paying if they're already purchasing
health insurance for someone else in the
family so um I think we're looking at
trying to you know like in private
insurance right there's for family
coverage sometimes you know there's a
certain charge premium charge stops at a
certain number of children or to have
the second or third child at a different
rate than the first child I think we we
do want to try to calibrate this to to
um be as
uh sensitive as possible to the
circumstances that particular example
that you gave me was one that I hadn't
thought about yet but you know we we do
a good part of this public process is
concerns can be raised and we can
incorporate that in our thinking how to
design it um but uh you know I think
there's uh there's a number of different
ways that we can you know structure the
premiums um and it'd be interesting you
know if you per chance if uh the example
that you brought up if there are
circumstances where sometimes can to be
cheaper to have everybody on ACA
coverage um when we were talking earlier
about the number of people children that
aren't on um it may be worthwhile in
that particular instance to evaluate
that with one of The Navigators as to
whether um being all under ACA coverage
as a family is less expensive than than
doing it both ways I'm not saying that
it is but those are the types of things
that we need to you know work with the
foundation for health communities who
does um the navigate contract of you
know trying to have that relationship to
look at and try to help people make the
best decision for themselves
financially thank you representative tki
for a question thank you um you just
said something that triggered a question
in my mind when we're talking about
number of children so um when we talk
about 5% of let's say that
working mom who makes $67,000 a year and
has two children um if she had four
children like of these month of these
premiums charged per child in the chip
program or if she has four children is
it the same amount family plan versus an
individual plan for children so I'd like
to in our design build in consideration
for the number of children in a
household and I think that we can um you
know there's a certain
um I mean that's what you do in in
typically uh employment sponsored
insurance right that there's that a one
person plan versus a two person plan
versus a family of plan based on certain
numbers so I think that um to try to to
look at the best we can on affordability
is to to model some different structures
we just haven't had the chance to do all
that work yet I understand that I guess
I'm just really concerned all of a
sudden that um
I wasn't into taking into account
multiple children I just assumed that
the
5% would provide the coverage for
everyone in the household that needed it
that was eligible so the the the to
Total that we could because it's based
on family income not the child's income
it's 5% is the total that we can collect
from a particular family right is 5% of
their income okay so I'm just wanting to
clarify that it's 5% of my mom my
hypothetical mom yeah um if she has one
child no I take that back because we're
talking about the $67,000 a year if she
has two children or five children it's
that $283 a month or however the math
works yeah I mean I think the the way
more way I'd say it from my perspective
is I can't exceed 5% of the family's
income okay I just want to make sure
that I'm understanding that it's not
yeah okay moving on to section
111 uh which is also on page
52 uh this provision here the Department
of Health and Human Services Medicaid
Eligibility this directs the department
to return to pre-public Health Emergency
income verification standards and on the
presentation slide that you have in
front of you what you'll see from a
general funds savings perspective is um
uh almost
um about almost around $17 million in
general funds over the bium in in total
savings as a result of that
provision and that is the last direct
hb2 can I
just representative tarki for a question
what's the direct what line are we
looking at on page 21 one that is that
verification sure so the the line is not
numbered but it is entitled Titan
eligibility requirements and you'll see
the
5.72 5 5.71 two million in general funds
in state fiscal year 26 and then the
11.4 million in state fiscal year 27 um
just just so folks are aware the the
table that you're looking at there
there's a few other reductions um up top
you will see a couple of unfunded
positions in resulting in in red Inc
there and then you'll also see a million
dollars each year in a a reduction to uh
the standard Medicaid budget and
accounting in at
7948 and there is no hb2 provision tied
to the unfunded positions or the uh
reduction the reduction to standard
Medicaid
can I ask one more questions yes
representative tki for a question Just
for future reference when we are blur
eyed in two weeks and looking at this
page can you refer the lines here that
correspond to the sections in hb2 do you
know what I'm saying like like I just
wrote section 110 in hb2 is Chip premium
that would be great we can reissue that
exhibit with that on there or you can
just do you have the can you do them
right now looking at the sections or is
it too much yes uh no I I can do it
right now okay um would you like to go
through from the top of the table down
or numerically through hb2 top of the
table down and we're just going to write
them down okay so the first row is
section 110 yep the next two rows have
no corresponding hb2
provision the fourth row the reduced
millim contract to One Rate adjustment
annually is section
108 the um reduce Alvarez and marel uh
contract I apologize I missed that
earlier that has no corresponding hb2
provision the preferred drug list
103 the increase Pharmacy cost sharing
is section
section1 the next row standard Medicaid
reduction has no corresponding hb2
provision
and then lastly section 109 ties to the
Medicaid premiums on granted advantage
much okay any further
questions all
right amazingly it's precisely 12:
noon um thank you very much for that and
for the presentation I'm sure if we have
anything or require any followup we'll
be in touch and I know you have some
follow-ups too so communication works
both ways so thank you both very much
thank you so it is 12: noon I do want to
make mention that if anyone from the
public would like to
speak I would welcome
you so why don't we begin that now if
anyone from the public would like to
speak on this continued work session on
Medicaid please come
forward if not we're going to close the
work session for the day okay two more
okay would the committee be all right to
um hear these individuals out prior to
our our break for lunch okay Qui so
we're not going to reconvene after the
afternoon discussion on FN 71 um if a
group of people come in and want to
testify then we will so we'll see how
this public testimony goes and then um
go from there so it's not correct to say
we're necessarily adjourned for the day
at this point that is correct I'll make
that determination once our public
participants have an opportunity to
testify welcome to division three if you
wouldn't mind stating your name real
clear and who you represent we would
appreciate it welcome absolutely and
I'll be very brief I know everyone wants
to get to lunch um my name is Jake Barry
I'm the vice president policy is add new
Futures as many of you know new Futures
is nonpartisan nonprofit Health policy
and advocacy organization we've been
working for nearly 30 years to increase
access to quality affordable healthcare
in our state uh just a quick comment
regarding the Medicaid cost shares
proposal that uh uh that that that Mr
liman and others just just referred to
uh I know we're awaiting more details
but I think it's important to note that
even modest cost shares proposed here uh
or modest cost increases like those
proposed here could have unintended
consequences and could significantly
impact uh access to care for many of our
states most
vulnerable uh research has repeatedly
confirmed that cost shares like premiums
and co-pays included in the budget are
associated with reduced care and
increased financial burden both for
enrolled individuals and and families
and the state as a whole in 2003 the
state of Oregon implemented sliding
scale premiums to enroll these below the
federal poverty line in that first year
enrollment drop by nearly half among the
affected population of course these
coverage declines contributed to the to
delayed or missing care and
significantly greater rates of
uncompensated care which had cost
impacts across the Health Care system in
addition I think it's important to note
that between lower enrollments and
higher administrative costs cost sharing
will likely not lead to to Savings in
2016 Arkansas experienced a 30% jump in
administrative cost associated with cost
sharing uh in Montana they disconsidered
discontinued two Provisions related to
premiums after 2 years due to
administrative and budgetary concerns uh
we fear administrative cost associated
with implementing these cost shares will
cost the state more than it saves and
then these initiatives will do little
but in decrease access to care for those
who need it increase uncompensated care
and create greater cost pressures across
the Health Care System uh with that I'm
happy to take questions or thank you for
your
time thank you and we certainly don't
want you to feel rushed uh based on
We're just trying to figure out today's
schedule no I understand no for sure
real good all right does anybody have
any questions for Mr
Barry all right all set thank you very
much a time check on your caucus
representative clairy what time does
that start noon did you say
Okay
Okay Okay uh
next welcome and if you could state your
name clear and who you represent we
would appreciate that thank you thank
you very much for your time and
attention uh this morning into this
afternoon for the record my name is Sam
Hawkins I'm here today representing Nami
New Hampshire the National Alliance on
men mental illness I just want to open
by saying on behalf of the individuals
and families we serve we know that
recovery is possible from mental illness
and substance use disorders but only
with access to the treatment people need
as the largest paay of mental health and
substance use disorder Services Medicaid
is a Lifeline for nearly 200,000 Granite
Staters through Medicaid coverage uh our
folks uh access critical services like
Psychotherapy inpatient treatment
prescription medications and Crisis Care
we have severe concerns that the
proposed changes to the Medicaid Program
implementing these policies that could
increase cost burden on beneficiaries or
create barriers to coverage would
disproportionately harm our folks with
mental health and substance use
conditions here in the granite state and
disc disconnect individuals and families
from the care they need I've printed out
a couple studies I I won't run through
them in detail but I do want to hit a
couple key points um according to the
Kaiser Family Foundation premiums do
serve as a barrier to obtaining and M
maintaining Medicaid coverage among
lowincome individuals and additionally
even relatively small levels of cost
sharing in the range of $1 to5 have been
associated with reduced use of care uh
cost sharing is also associated with
worse health health outcomes and
increased financial burden uh for
example in one study after the
implementation of co-pays for
prescription drugs utilization
significantly declined in another study
for individuals with schizophrenia for
every $1 increase in the prescription
co- payment there was a reduction in the
amount of medication fills and then I
just want to note that uh we know that
when parents have health insurance their
children are more likely to be insured
so uh really this is about impacting the
entire family access to care for the
entire family so the way we see it a lot
of these proposed changes will only lead
to decreases in coverage which will lead
to decreases in access to care which
will lead to worse mental health
outcomes for individuals and family here
in the granite state
so uh for those reasons Nami New
Hampshire urges finance division 3 to
exercise caution when considering uh
these proposed changes especially cost
sharing and premiums and really
prioritize access to care and I thank
you for your time and I will hand out
these
studies thank you thanks any questions
for Mr
Hawkins thank you all set thank
you and next yes I think we're ready
okay all right if you could just welcome
yes you know state your name clearly and
who you represent would be appreciated
yes thank you so much for the
opportunity this my name is Don mckenny
I work for New Hampshire legal
assistance and I I want to try to um
highlight a couple things without
repeating everything that was just said
by the previous um two folks who I
completely support everything that they
just mentioned um in terms of things
like the fact that this essentially a
lot of these changes will essentially um
lead to churn in the Medicaid Program
meaning people who are eligible for
these programs will lose eligibility not
because they're not poor not because
they're not sick but because they fail
to complete whatever document it is
that's required that in the case of the
passive renewals for example I'm sorry
the expart renewals for example these
things were put in place to make it
easier both for the state employ where
you've already heard yesterday we have a
23% vacancy rate right so they're going
to have to do more work which costs the
state more money and puts more burden on
state employees to do that work when we
currently have these
vacancies um and the the actual
individuals um who are currently getting
renewed um passively with this xte
process it's because things like if you
you know look on the the slide 15 um
that was mentioned earlier removal of
the Z employment income test that means
essentially right
now if if the database which they use
that gets all collects all the income
information says that someone has zero
dollars like income currently they're
allowed to renew them because they have
zero income this would make them get
documentation that that person has zero
income that you know so we're putting
things into place to make it harder for
people to stay enrolled who are eligible
so I just wanted to kind of put a finer
point on that
um again we've heard about the cost
savings that are that the that will be
associated with each of these policy
changes in each B2 but I I would like
clarification about whether they are
these are gross or net savings mean
meaning each of these changes also cost
money um to do more uh work to make sure
renewals are no longer done ex expar to
implement a premium program to implement
co-pays I mean um yeah the prescription
drug co-pays all of those changes cost
money to implement we know previous we
when we did the work requirement it cost
$4.4 million to implement um that wasn't
actually uh that was frozen but we the
state spent money to implement it um
likewise there would be costs associated
with implementing each of these changes
and I haven't heard anything about those
costs so I guess I just would like
clarification whether gross or net here
in terms of savings and I'd also like to
know and I know I realize I'm asking you
questions that you can't necessarily
answer I guess they're just questions
for your consideration as you consider
these decisions in the budget
how many people are expected to lose
coverage based on each of these
Provisions because um we've again talked
about the cost savings well $12 million
for for example for one of the cost CH
premiums I think it was the $12 million
represents money collected but it also
represents um in in some way it it must
represent people who lose coverage right
like who are expected to lose coverage
so that's a savings to the state
um I just like to hear those numbers as
well I think those are important to
making an informed decision about each
of these items and I'll stop there
because I know you're probably as hungry
as I am don't let that stop you though
we I think that's I think I I think I
covered what I wanted to cover okay
thank you for bringing those things to
our attention any questions for the
witness I just wanted to say yes I just
wanted to thank you uh Miss mckin and
everyone else who who stuck through and
spoke and we I know we'll have more
questions so um we look forward to
seeing you over the com coming weeks
because we need your your expertise in
helping us determine those questions
thank you thank
you any further comments from the
public okay it appears yes
representative
priest while we have Mr Lipman here I
would like to have for all the
provisions that um are in the HB to
listed how many people will be affected
and what is the cost savings you may not
have the numbers now but I would like to
see for each provision section that
you
okay anything further from division
three okay we're in a position now where
we're going to close the work session
the continued work session on Medicaid
for today we will not resume this work
session this afternoon however division
3 members do come back at 1:00 to take
up House Bill 71 my apologies if you're
late for your next
commitment this work session is
all
e
all right it's uh now 1:00 uh division 3
work session is going to get started um
we're here today to um
rediscussed hopefully some conclusion
about
hp71 um uh there's been side talk of uh
of a non-gain amendment being attached
to this uh we can't talk about that
today because it needs to go in front of
a full another full finance committee
hearing before we can really consider
consider it as something we we we could
or or that we might want to attach to
hp71 so for the purposes of
today uh HB 71 is kind of a standalone
Bill and and and uh and that's all we're
doing uh do we have a motion so we can
begin a
discussion yes so representative Daniels
moves ought to pass is there a second
uh seconded by
representative
Nano um uh do you do you want to start
the discussion representative Daniels do
what what what are your what are your
thoughts on on this bill we don't we
don't have anyone from the policy side
of this we I know that the vice chair
made good efforts uh to encourage a
policy person to be here um but that
just didn't happen everyone is just busy
I guess guess so um so with that uh I
think we can discuss this amongst
ourselves or have
to I I don't really have much more to
add Ian we discussed this once before
yeah and um so I don't think I have
really anything more to add than what I
did back then all right um so so I go
ahead representa Moy thank you Mr
chairman so just as a refresher this
bill on the published do ET came out of
Education policy and
administration it was recommended ought
to pass by that committee with a vote of
10 to
7 and then an ought to pass
recommendation for the Full House roll
call
146 yeah that's why we got it we don't
get the ones that
fail um okay so I I think when I'm
hearing you uh do that summary um
representative Mooney that um
essentially the the the policy decision
has been made by the house that position
has been taken um is there is there any
discussion on wanting to to readdress
the policy although it's been kind of
settled at this point you have your mic
on I don't know if you have a comment I
do but you're you're it doesn't address
the question you just asked oh um but
addresses the bill so so we'll do
whatever you have to say and then we can
come back sure I um uh thank you not not
addressing the underlying policy itself
but we did hear some uh particularly
potentially
alarming testimony that um that
implementation taking the position uh as
the state of New Hampshire on the this
bill uh May conflict with with Federal
guidance and put uh Financial monies
that we receive uh from the uh
Department of Housing and Urban
Development at risk and it um uh and I
think there's a tradeoff between uh
having you know addressing this
relatively rare circumstances that's
talked about in the bill versus a a
fairly significant uh source of State
funds and I I just didn't see see the
need for this bill given given uh the
the testimony that was uniquely provided
here to the finance committee right so
so um if I may I I um I everything you
just said was accurate I I I think what
you said is necessary I I don't view it
as being sufficient to the discussion
around the fiscal note though I I I
think the testimony was was um I my
interpretation was that it was fairly
clear clear that what was laid out in
the in the fiscal note was the worst
case and that when I asked uh the the
the the person from the Department who
was
testifying what the best case may be or
what the most likely probable case is I
I I I believe her answer was that uh she
didn't really think about it she hadn't
really thought about it and then in
discussion I I I asked her you know is
it probably is zero is that the best
case that this is going to have no
impact and uh and I think she after I
asked her the question that way she
accepted that that was in indeed a
possibility that that's the way I
remember it but um um is there
representative
tki I had a different comment I shut it
off in case anyone else wanted to
respond okay do we want to keep
representative
seaworth thank you Mr chairman
um when I was in in that and listening
to the
explanation
um I interpreted some of the statements
maybe maybe read into them the
explanation as to why the worst case was
considered um was that they didn't
understand the meaning of the words as
written uh which right I found a little
frustrating because there words that are
defined in federal law and the reference
is very explicit to the federal law
right so
the the basis upon which she Drew her
conclusion was based on an incorrect
definition there there's a very specific
subset of people that are refer to and
the testimony was that well I'm not sure
what that means it could be everybody
and if it's everybody then that would be
illegal and
unconstitutional in which case we could
lose all our money and I I think that
ignores the ability to Simply look at
the definitions and they're not the law
isn't complicated in this case simply
review um is there any comment more on
the fiscal note because if there if if
the members don't have one i' I'd like
to ask Mr Ripple who got you this is a
little unusual but you were involved
from the LDA LBA perspective on uh
developing this fiscal note I believe do
you have any deeper context to share
with us that we haven't already
discussed I don't think so I had already
distributed the uh the exact line items
and amounts that HHS was referencing
sort of generally when they gave me that
fiscal note information I will just make
one other General comment which is it's
fairly typical um when HHS provides a
response to a bill um that has some
bearing on federal law they will often
say that in the extreme case or in the
worst case scenario this bill if passed
May jeopardize federal funds of X dollar
so that's not an uncommon response from
HHS all
right represent lurki what whatever you
care to say go for it wow well get
ready um
no I guess what I'm hearing in the uh
the weaknesses in the fiscal note
pertains a lot to the specific language
and the definitions in the bill um I
think we asked a lot of questions about
what does this mean what does that mean
and the reality is there was not a clear
answer and while I'd like to Simply say
I'm looking at the fiscal note to make
my decision I'm looking at the the
language of the bill and I believe it is
poorly written unfortunately and so I
cannot support an ought to pass motion
on the bill because it's connected to a
fiscal note that doesn't make any sense
so I won't be supporting the a to pass I
I think I think I actually share a
portion of your observation there um and
I spent some time talking to the sponsor
uh and a co-sponsor about uh potential
Amendment to the policy aspect of it and
um the strong preference of the of the
um of the Prime sponsor was uh uh let's
not do any more changes in the house and
the extent that it may need an amendment
or somebody might want an amendment
defer it to the Senate and I I don't um
I I I'm I'm okay with the supporting the
uh sponsors desire there and if I may
the fact that the sponsor has not not
once come before this committee to help
answer our questions I find extremely
frustrating and I believe that that's
bad governance to P push this through to
the Senate and hope that someone else
changes it so again I'm going to be
voting now I I respect your opinion and
and it's really not all that different
than my own if you truth be told so uh
representative priest thank you Mr
chairman welcome back I also share the
same opinion as
my uh representative across the uh room
um there is no problem in New Hampshire
there has been no problem in New
Hampshire this is not a
problem this is something that is we
shouldn't be looking at
because number one it's not a problem
and why are we even entertaining
this I I I think in discussions with the
sponsor though this has been an issue in
Massachusetts which is next next door to
us so it it's it's not a totally foreign
idea but but Mr Mr chairman I appreciate
that but if this was a problem in
Massachusetts why would wasn't the
sponsor here to give us this information
she wasn't here at all and so we have
vague language we're going in with a um
fiscal note that may or may not be
devastating to our communities and
and
um I I can't vote on it yeah well you
can vote you can't I can I can vote I
can vote I'm opposed to this and and and
I yes no I I I hear you yeah uh
representative stringam so one of the
one of the things that that I heard or
uh what I believe I heard was talking
about the 72 hours in the bill so
basically you know you have an emergency
shelter you use a school schools are
great they're available able low cost
for those
circumstances but on within 72 hours you
have to have some method of
verifying uh the resident status of
everybody who's in there and uh if you
don't do it adequately that's the then
the worst case scenario comes through
you lose funds I think one of one of the
things a responsible government might do
in re in response to this is no longer
use schools as emergency shelter so what
we'd have available is uh more expensive
yeah maybe less quality schools um uh
because that's just such an honorous uh
own onerous thing to prove that
everybody who was in there on the 73rd
hour is um is there so so and and that's
that's real real cost to the budget and
to this to the state to do that so yes
sir can can I respond to that sure uh
okay so um so you've suggested an
alternative policy position um and
unless you have an amendment for us to
debate I I don't know that we should be
amending the policy I mean you've got a
good
perspective um but um I think having uh
planned for Emergency Operations before
uh to your point schools with
gymnasiums are a beautiful thing and the
closer they are to the impact Ed people
kind of the better proximity matters in
a disaster right so I I don't know if if
it were a separate policy debate if
there were an amendment like that I I
don't know that I would want to take it
out of the hands of the local people to
use an emergency shelter operation for
72 hours and and and and and and and
again no having seen these kind of plans
before u a a law enforcement component
is typically associated ated so even
during that first 72 hours without
identification of you know potential um
uh human threats to the rest of them uh
there would typically be some law
enforcement capability to um maintain
good order and discipline
um give them 72 hours to sort sort it
out um that's that would be my point of
view representative
seaworth thank you Mr chairman I want to
kind of offer a counter um I in fact
find this language very clear and and
very specific uh extremely narrow in its
scope and impact um I'm not saying this
is I think the language is is perfect um
but
I my vote would be determined by the
opposite not saying well this looks like
you know who knows what's going to
happen and it's it's certainly going to
be a disaster I think when you look at
the when you actually read through
everything understand it and look at
when it would
apply maybe to your point maybe it
hardly it's almost impossible that it
comfortable deciding for myself that
these worst case scenarios simply are
not possible so I don't want to put
words in your mouth you would be prone
to to voting OTP and and and basically
um not disregarding but um
contextualizing the fiscal note to a
point where you're not really concerned
about its
relevance yes all right and do you mind
sharing with us why you may have a
slightly better insight into this
immigration issue than the rest of us
you don't have to I I know we've talked
and you you you have a a better Source
than I do I I probably shouldn't all
right no problem I'll I'll I I probably
shouldn't because I don't think it's
relevant my what what everything I said
is based on reading the bill and reading
the the federal law so okay so I'll just
say that based on what I uh uh think I
know uh your point of view is
particularly credible to
me so uh representative
wner could we move the question yeah we
can okay uh Representative no vanle just
a ju just a quick comment to uh Echo uh
I think what chairman Edwards said
relevant to uh representative
stringham's comments you know uh rep
representative Stringham and I'm sure if
you thought through it um the
alternative that you're representing is
is throwing the baby out with the bath
water and I would suggest that we had a
flood we had an emergency situation in
elstead in 2005 was pretty pretty
serious ripped out killed four people
and I can tell you that one of the first
things that they're definitely police
presence National Guard uh on scene and
they were Sheltering uh people who had
lost homes and one of the first
activities they do is try to determine
who uh who is affected so they they're
getting information on who was who was
in the shelters and they were doing that
almost immediately so I would con confer
con you know concur with the observation
that 72 hours is plenty of time they've
got to you know in in that case they to
decide who was missing in some of the
houses that had gotten destroyed you
know so that exercise is kind of a
routine matter determine who who is
affected who's impacted and you know
take names and addresses so that's my
two cents so so I don't know all the
rules of the house but I I I heard
representative walner suggest we just go
to a vote and so uh I I are are is
everyone ready for a vote um um Mr clerk
would you let's go ahead and and do this
vote representative Edwards uh
yes representative Mooney
yes representative Daniels
yes representative seaworth
yes myself
no representative
walner representative Stringham
no representative Priest
No okay all all members being present
and voting the the tally is 5 to4
OTP all right um thank you uh we should
U know now uh who would be drafting uh
various uh majority and a Minority
Report will there be a Minority Report
when it comes can I ask a question sorry
I don't mean to interrupt you I don't
recall doing that last by any or the
first year that and I I guess I'm a
little taken aback that we're just
hate to say our that our discussion
won't matter in our full Finance
debate okay I I don't want to presuppose
that but I would like to get the altern
there will be a Minority Report I I know
but but one of the thing the reason I'm
asking about it now is because I want to
make sure that when it comes out of
Finance we're immediately ready to put
the package together to send to the
clerk's office this has been one of the
issues that the speaker and the clerk
and an I forget Ann's last name Gerald
yeah has been asking us to make sure
that we get these packages in as quickly
as possible so if I say to you that
there will be a Minority Report before
the end of the day when we exec this is
that sufficient yes ma'am great there
will be a Minority Report when we
execute all right no that's good I my
intent is to give you an army terms a
warning order so you can begin thinking
about it and have it ready when it's
time is there anyone that wants to write
a majority report or excuse me I'm
presuming the vote the the the
the a a report that would support the
decision of division three I can do all
right okay um so has
everyone I think we're I think we're
done with hp71 i i as I said I do think
we're going to try to get the non gerain
amendment to it um I in formally i' I've
heard that there's really not any
opposition to the non- gerain amendment
Maybe I'm Wrong maybe there'll be a
change of heart but uh but we'll do that
in the full finance committee next time
we can get it
scheduled in on the wall inside um right
to the left U of Janet and by the uh
copier there's a very long list of 2025
house bills and it's dated the 3rd of
March there's 25 bills that we're
projecting to come to house
finance um it shows that the projected
divisions um obviously include 71 for
division
three um and of the 25 the only other
one is 519 we've already disposed of it
so while the other uh divisions are
busily working on Phils we're we're
we're sort of um wrapped up in ours
we're done um but uh we don't know
what's going to happen with the house uh
on
Thursday there any questions about
future legislative work for us um to the
question you asked yesterday representa
walner about um when we're going to do
the public session I all indications are
it's it's March 12th was noticed in our
emails about half hour ago as 2 p.m. on
March 12th it's 2 p.m. on March 12th
just check in with the ranking member
I'll be sure to set everyone straight
all right thank you um all right so uh
is there anything else for the the good
of the division before we break huddle
and go ahead representative Mooney thank
you today by for the this morning by the
way people are curious why I wasn't here
I I have this house issue that I'm I got
to flip over and start getting it rented
and today was supposed to be the
conclusion of all of the repairs and
stuff to have it rentable and so I had
contractor issues and then I had payment
issues and then I had Bank issues so uh
I I I I do apologize that my personal
life got in the way of of being here and
but I know that you all handled it so
well thank you Mr chairman and good to
have you back
just want to remind the members that we
meet again as division 3 Monday March
10th Tuesday March 11 Wednesday March 12
all starting at 10:00 a.m. thank
you do you have finished times for that
those March 12th our full Finance
hearing starts at 2 and since this is
the only hearing that's scheduled for
the public and it is in rep's Hall we
should presume there will be a lot of
interest so pack a snack that's my take
on
it what do represent wner what's our
requirement for the committee members to
be at the public hearing what I I I know
it's good courtesy I know we should be
there but but what what what what sort
of U house rules or or or uh tradition
or protocols uh have we had in the past
on that I don't believe there's any
house rules I would hope that everyone
would want to be there and hear what the
public have to say right I mean and
we've had excellent attendance in the
past from the well I hope we continue I
was just curious if there was some sort
of historical protocol even when we
traveled we went to many we went to
other communities in the state and had
public hearings and often we'd have
almost the full finance committee
traveling to those places so I would
think if it's right across the street we
can all get
there okay getting there and staying
there may be different for some people's
personal lives I don't know but but for
the expectation of the members is when
it starts it to we we stay other than
bathroom
breaks um go ahead representative tersi
I was simply going to say it's too bad
that um it's starting so late in the day
I it would have been good to allow more
availability for the public to show up
um with a onewe notice it's just
unfortunate that there maybe couldn't be
two sessions one offsite start in the
morning but it is what it is um sure and
because he's my boss I'm just going to
also say that U having some availability
after 5:00 pm when people get off work
actually recognizes that the public
behaves differently than we do and it
may meet their
needs would have been nice also to have
a an evening one but it will be
evening well I mean
I mean one that could start presumably
for those iar if I Wasing I'm just going
to keep defending my chairman that's
fine if I was working and saw a 2 p.m.
start my my gut reaction would be by the
time I got out of work and got maybe got
my children to some kind of child care
that uh I it wouldn't be assured that by
the time I drove up to conquer from
nashaa that it would still be going at
6:30 7 o' at night so I think it's still
going to be on Zoom so it isn't that the
public it isn't loed out then you can't
speak I know everyone knows that and I'm
just making sure that everyone out there
knows that too please show up if you
want to ask questions dear public um Mr
Ripple
anything all right okay so that's it